GOOD AFTERNOON.
WELCOME TO THE MARCH TWENTIETH
HEARING OF THE ASSEMBLY HUMAN
SERVICES COMMITTEE TODAY WE HAVE
THIRTEEN BILLS AND ONE
RESOLUTION UP.
SEVEN OF WHICH ARE ON CONSENT AS
A REMINDER WE ALLOW TWO MINUTE
TWO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF TWO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION FOR EACH
BILL. EACH OF THESE WITNESSES
SHOULD LIMIT THEIR TESTIMONY TO
TWO MINUTES ANY ADDITIONAL WHEN
THIS IS ME AT ON THEIR SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION BY STATING ONLY
THEIR NAME AND ORGANIZATION.
WE DON'T HAVE A QUORUM YET BUT
DOCTOR CHOI IS HERE SO IF WE MAY
ARE GOING TO GET STARTED THE
SUBCOMMITTEE AND THEN WHEN WE.
HAVE CRIME WILL GO AHEAD AND
STOP AND I ESTABLISH QUORUM.
THANK YOU DOCTOR TREE.
OKAY.
LET'S SEE.
MOST.
YEAH MISTER HOLDEN IF YOU MAY.
SINCE YOU'RE HERE PATIENTLY
WAITING FOR US PLEASE COME.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR IT'S A
PLEASURE TO BE HERE AND TO JOIN
WITH YOU AND.
YOUR COMMITTEE OF ONE FOR NOW.
.
THERE IS ZERO.
BUT THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING US TO
PRESENT.
AB TWENTY THREE SEVENTY.
I LIKE TO START OFF BY ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS OF FOR AB TWENTY
THREE SEVENTY.
THIS BILL REQUIRES THE
DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD TO ADOPT
REQUIREMENTS TO ENSURE THE
CHILDCARE CENTERS DRINKING WATER
IS LEAD FREE.
THE BILL ALSO ALLOWS ALL LICENSE
CHILD HERE.
GILES DAYCARE FACILITIES TO
BORROW NO INTEREST LOANS TO PAY
FOR LEAD CLEANUP AND DRINKING
WATER SYSTEM IMPROVEMENTS.
DRINKING WATER AND MOST
CHILDCARE CENTERS IS NOT TESTED
FOR LEAD.
THIS IS THE PROBLEM BECAUSE MANY
WATER PIPES FAUCETS AND
FIXTURES.
STILL ARE IN USE.
CONTAINED LEAD IN OVERTIME THIS
LEAD CAN LEACH INTO THE DRINKING
WATER. YET WE KNOW YOUNG
CHILDREN ARE THE MOST HARMED BY
LEAD BECAUSE THEY ABSORB MUCH.
OF THE LEAD DAY IN JUST.
ACCORDING TO AMERICAN ACADEMY
FOR PEDIATRICS AND CENTERS FOR
DISEASE CONTROL THERE IS NO SAFE
LEVEL OF LEAD.
CHILLED IN CHILDREN.
LEAD SEVERE NEUROTOXIN
EVEN MINUTE AMOUNTS OF LEAD IN
THE BODIES OF YOUNG VERY YOUNG
CHILDREN. CAUSE HARM TO THEIR
CENTRAL NERVOUS SYSTEM AND THIS
HARM APPEARS TO BE HEARD
IRREVERSIBLE.
AB TWENTY THREE SEVENTY WILL
HELP KEEP YOUNG OUR YOUNGEST
CHILDREN SAFE BY ENSURING THAT
THEY ARE NOT INGESTING LEAD
THROUGH THE WATER THEY DRINK.
I HAVE WITH ME CRISTINA HATE.
SENIOR POLICY ADVISER HAD
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
NUTRITION POLICY INSTITUTE
DIVISION OF AGRICULTURAL AND
NATURAL RESOURCES. AND SUSAN
LITTLE FROM THE VARMINT WORKING
GROUP I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU
RIGHT.
THANK YOU.
GOV.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU MY NAME
AS CRISTINA HECHT AND I'M SENIOR
POLICY ADVISER AT THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA.
NUTRITION POLICY INSTITUTE WHICH
IS AND THEN DIVISION OF
AGRICULTURE AND NATURAL
RESOURCES.
NUTRITION POLICY INSTITUTE
ENGAGES IN RESEARCH TO SUPPORT
POLICY AND I FOCUS ON DRINKING
WATER AND WORK WITH RESEARCHERS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
FEDERAL AND CALIFORNIA NUTRITION
LEGISLATION PROVIDE GREAT ACCESS
TO DRINKING WATER FOR CHILDREN
IN LICENSED CHILDCARE. BUT OUR
CONCERN IS THAT THEY IGNORE THE
SAFETY PIECE.
LEAD IS MOST TOXIC TO CHILDREN
UNDER AGE SIX AND EVEN MORE TO
CHILDREN UNDER AGE THREE.
THIS IS BECAUSE CHILDREN ABSORB
BLOOD MORE READILY.
AND ALSO THERE GROWING BRAINS
ARE MORE SUSCEPTIBLE TO DAMAGE.
YOUNG CHILDREN CAN'T ABSORB UP
TO FIT FORTY TO FIFTY PERCENT OF
THE LEAD THAT THEY IN CHEST.
FORMULA FED INFANTS ARE EVEN
GREATER RISK.
THIS IS BECAUSE THEY CONSUME THE
MOST WATER PER BODY WEIGHT.
SIXTY PERCENT OF BABIES ARE
EXCLUSIVELY FORMULA FED AND THEY
DRINK UP TO FOUR CUPS OF WATER
PER DAY IN THEIR RECONSTITUTED
FORMULA.
FORTY TO SIXTY PERCENT OF
INFANTS EXPOSURE TO LEAD IS
THROUGH WATER USED TO MIX
FORMULA.
THERE'S ANOTHER REASON TO CARE
ABOUT TAP WATER SAFETY.
DRINKING WATER INSTEAD OF SUGARY
DRINKS IS A GREAT WAY TO REDUCE
INTAKE OF THE EMPTY CALORIES IN
ADDED SUGAR SUTTER SUCH A
CONTRIBUTOR. TO DIET RELATED
CHRONIC DISEASE INCLUDING
DIABETES TYPE TWO ONE DENTAL
CAVITIES.
WE WANT PEOPLE TO FEEL CONFIDENT
ABOUT THEIR TAP WATER SAFETY SO
THAT THEY CAN DRINK.
WATER INSTEAD OF SUGARY TRACKS.
WE TOUCHED WATER BEFORE IT
LEAVES THE UTILITY BUT THERE'S
ALMOST NO TESTING OF WATER AT
THE TAP.
CALIFORNIA SHOULD BE A FRONT
RUNNER IN ASSURING SAFE DRINKING
WATER IN LICENSED CHILDCARE
CENTERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
COME TO TALK.
TO PRESENT BEFORE YOU ABOUT THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS SUSAN LITTLE I'M WITH
THE ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING GROUP
THE SPONSOR OF THE BILL.
AND AS MENTIONED LOW LET LOW
EVEN LOW LEVELS OF LEAD EXPOSURE
CAN REDUCE A CHILD'S IQ AND
COGNITIVE ABILITIES AND.
UNFORTUNATELY WE NOW KNOW THAT
THOSE.
THAT DAMAGE CAN LAST FOR A
CHILD'S LIFE TIME AND REDUCE
THEIR LIFE THEIR LIFE OUTCOMES.
IN FACT ONE IN FRONT THAT
AMERICA CAT ME PEDIATRICS STATES
THAT ONE IN FIVE CASES OF
CHILDHOOD. ADHD IS ATTRIBUTABLE
TO LEAD EXPOSURE.
AND SADLY CHILDREN WERE
MALNOURISHED ABSORBED LED MUCH
FASTER.
AND WE DO KNOW THAT EIGHTY EIGHT
PERCENT OF LEAD POISONED KIDS IN
CALIFORNIA COME FROM LEAD FROM
LOW INCOME FAMILIES.
UNFORTUNATE MOST OF THESE KIDS
ARE NOT TESTED FOR LEAD EXPOSURE
SO WE DON'T REALLY HAVE A. GOOD
HANDLE ON THE EXTENT OF THE LEAD
EXPOSURE PROBLEM IN CALIFORNIA.
WE DO NO THAT LEAD EXPOSURE IS
PREVENTABLE AND WE CAN BECAUSE
WE CAN REMOVE LEAD.
SUCH AS LEAD THAT'S IN WATER.
AND RECENTLY.
CHILDCARE FACILITIES AT SCHOOL
SITES HAVE BEEN HAVING TO TEST
THEIR WATER.
AND SOME OF THE SITES OF SOME OF
THEM ARE OKAY SOME OF THE SITES
TO HAVE ELEVATED PRETTY HELD
ELEVATED LEVELS. AND AFFECT
WONDERING ONE CHILD CARE CENTER
IN OAKLAND. HAD SEVEN THERE ITS
WATER HAD SEVENTEEN TIMES THE
ALLOWABLE LIMIT OF LEAD IN THAT
DRINKING WATER.
IT'S A AB TWENTY THREE SEVENTY
REQUIRES DSS TO IT AND FORCED TO
ENSURE THAT SENT THE CENTERS
DRINKING WATER IS LEAD FREE. AND
BASICALLY JUST WHEN FORCED THEIR
EXISTING LICENSING STANDARDS
SO THANK YOU WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE SUPPORT
FOR THE BILL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU.
ANY OTHER.
IT'S ONE.
OKAY.
ACTUALLY CAN WE ESTABLISH CORN
PLEASE.
RUBIO.
START CHOI.
ARAMBULA.
MAIENSCHEIN.
RESTS.
STONE.
BERMAN.
THANK YOU ARM IF THERE ARE ANY
OUT WITNESSES ARE ALLAH ANY.
SUPPORT.
PLEASE COME UP
THE ONLY SUPPORT COMES UP HERE.
THANK YOU KEVIN AS THEN COLUSA
CALIFORNIA WELFARE RIGHTS
ORGANIZATIONS
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
BECAUSE THAT POISONING THE
PORTION THE IMPACT. LOW INCOME
KIDS MR KELBERG'S KIDS
THAT IN I ORIGINAL I PUT THANK
YOU.
TRUTH ANDERSON ON BEHALF OF THE
ARCANE UCP CALIFORNIA
COOPERATION AND SUPPORT.
RICK ROLLINS ON BEHALF OF ARCA
SITUATION REGIONAL CENTER
AGENCIES IN SUPPORT.
JIM WYNBERG ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
TO CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
AND I'D ALSO LIKE TO.
CHIME IN SUPPORT FOR THE CLEAN
WATER ACTION PARENTS.
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
K. HEARING NONE ALL BUT BRING IT
UP TO THE THE COMMITTEE. ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THANK.
THANK YOU I HAVE A A MOTIONS I
CONDUCTED CHOI.
NOW OBVIOUSLY THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE OF FOR
CHILDREN'S SAFETY. AND THE LIEU
LET LEVEL.
KA I'M STRUGGLING.
EVEN THOUGHT THE ISSUE THE SAME
POLL RUN.
HOWEVER A WE ARE KNOW THAT.
TOO MANY REGULATIONS SAW ARE
ARE PREVENTING.
QUAN NECESSARY.
A CHILD CARE FACILITIES SO.
BEING OPENED.
AND.
AND THIS IS A AND OF THOUGH
LAYER OF FOG REQUIREMENTS.
AND THE EVEN THOUGH WE ORDERED
REALIZE HOW IMPORTANT. THAT YOU
JUST HAVE ISSUES ARE.
BUT THE.
CHILD CARE INSTITUTIONS SO.
OF.
MAY BE.
THERE MAY BE SOME SOME OLD ONES
ABOUT THE NEW ONES SO.
LIKELY WOULD HAVE FOR NEW PIE
BUT.
AND A VERY.
YEAH LEADERS CHAD SAID THAT THAT
THAT LEVEL WOULD BE HIGHER THAN.
.
AND AT THAT THAT REQUIRED THE
WHOEVER.
THE WHOLE ROOM SAID THEY COME
FROM.
ARE ARE LIKELY.
THAT THEY WOULD HAVE OR THE
PIPES AND THAT HAVE FOR. MORE
LEAD LEVELS.
WHY DO WE HAVE TO FOCUS UPON
ONLY CHILD CARE CENTERS?
CHILDREN COME FROM HOMES
WHAT ABOUT THE OR THE HOMES
WENDELL BOTTOM.
BUT WAY APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR.
YOUR THOUGHTS ON THIS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER I THINK.
FOR SMALL ARE.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT.
IDEALLY THAT.
WHERE?
NOT ONLY ARE CHILDREN ARBOR
WHERE WHATEVER.
WHEREVER WE ARE AND WE'RE ACCESS
SEEN ALL WATER THAT. WE HAVE A
HIGH DEGREE OF ASSURANCE THAT IF
THERE'S.
AUG MINIMAL OF NO LEAD IN THE
WATER.
.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE K. THROUGH
TWELVE.
THERE ARE STANDARDS THAT ARE IN
PLACE.
TESTING.
THERE ARE NONE CURRENTLY AS IT
RELATES TO CHILDCARE CENTERS.
THERE ARE OVER SEVEN HUNDRED
THOUSAND CHILDREN WHO WERE IN
CHILDCARE CENTERS.
EVERYDAY.
AND TO THE EXTENT THAT WE CAN DO
SOMETHING TO ADDRESS.
CURRENT CONDITIONS AND MAKING
SURE THAT IF THERE IS LED.
THAT WE IN THE WATER THAT WE ARE
RECOGNIZING THAT AND THEN WE CAN
START A PROCESS OF REMEDIATION.
AND SO IT'S A APPROPRIATE NEXT
STEP.
WHEN YOU MENTION OVER
REGULATION I THINK THAT'S THE
REASON FOR THIS BILL THERE IS.
NO REGULATION CURRENTLY TO
ADDRESS LET TESTING FOR.
CHILDCARE CENTERS AT IN TERMS OF
NEW FACILITIES.
.
NO THAT'S GREAT IF THEY'RE BEING
BUILT AND YOU'RE RIGHT THEY
WOULD BE.
BILL TO CERTAIN STANDARDS THAT.
YOU WOULD ASSUME WOULD HAVE ALL
OF THE. OUR PROTOCOLS IN PLACE
TO ENSURE THAT.
LET US CAP OF THE WATER BUT TO
THE EXTENT THAT.
THAT COULD EVEN BE LEACHED AND.
OUT SOMEHOW WE JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT PARENTS AND TEACHERS
AND THOSE WHO ARE.
SAFEGUARDING THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY AREA PEOPLE. UNDERSTAND
WHETHER THEIR CHILDREN ARE AT AN
ENVIRONMENT WHERE THERE'S OF
POTENTIAL FOR A LEAD TO LEACH
INTO THE WATER SYSTEM THEREBY
CREATING.
THESE KIND OF HARMFUL SAFETY
CONDITIONS THAT IMPACT ON A
CHILD'S ABILITY TO.
.
LEARN AND ALSO.
KEEP HIM SAFE AND SO WE THINK
THIS IS APPROPRIATE STEP WE
DON'T THINK THAT THIS IS A.
FALLS IN THE CATEGORY OF OVER
REGULATED IT'S IS REGULATING.
SOMETHING THAT CURRENTLY IS NOT.
AT THE PROPER OVERSIGHT. AND
GREATER A HIGHER STANDARD OF
SAFETY AND ENVIRONMENT WHERE
YOUNG PEOPLE ARE.
YEAH.
M..
I'M STRUGGLING OUT OF BETWEEN
THE.
THE RETURN REGULATIONS SO VERSUS
A.
AND CHILDREN'S A SAFETY AND A
CHILDREN'S SAFETY IS A FORMER SO
YOU KNOW MORE IMPORTANT TO OUR
CHILDREN ABOUT A LOT MORE I
THINK YOU DECIDE HOW WE CAN
COMPROMISE SO. HOW OFTEN THE
WATER HAS TO BE TESTED THE FOR
EXAMPLE?
IF NOT BE EVERY MONTH I EVERY
SIX MONTHS EVERY YEAR WITH TWO
YEARS OF THREE YEARS.
IF AND WHEN THAT THE WATER
LEVEL.
DID LEAD LEVEL IS SO HIGH IT AN
ARE. OF THE QUIET THOSE
STANDARDS ARE THEN. A WILL THERE
BE ANY SUBSTITUTE ON THE KEBAB
INTO WATER O.. O. WALK TEND
WATER WHATEVER CAN BE PROVIDED
TO INSTEAD OF A TABLET WE HAVE
TO SPEAK ABOUT THE TAP WATER YOU
RIGHT.
YES.
IF I IF I MA'AM SUSAN LITTLE
AGAIN WITH ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING
GROUP SO. I'D NATIONWIDE THERE'S
MEANT ABOUT SIX OTHER STATES
THAT HAVE BEEN IMPOSED.
DRINKING WATER TESTING STANDARDS
ON CHILDCARE CENTERS AND
FACILITIES. AND THOSE STANDARDS
TYPICALLY REQUIRED RETESTING
ABOUT EVERY SIX YEARS.
EVERY CITY EVERY SIX YEARS AND
THIS IS A BILL TO ME.
I'M SORRY  I FEAR OBVIOUS
YURI'S ABOUT IT THAT HAS TO BE A
EVERY YEAR AND SIX YEARS HIS SON
IN ROME POP CAN HAVE A RUSHED TO
WALK ON THAT LEVEL. YOU KNOW WHY
NOT EVERY YEAR HERE AND THEN.
I'LL LET.
I THINK THAT THE WATER.
SUPPLY WETA TAP WATER OF
WHATEVER THAT WATER IS TIPPING
PEOPLE BEING.
PROVIDED TO CHILDREN CAN BE
TESTED THAT IF THAT THE LEVEL IS
ABOVE FLOOD AND SUBSTITUTE A
RATHER THAN.
DE CHILD CARE CENTER PERMIT
THIS OUT FOR.
WOULD BE DEPENDING UPON THE TAP
WATER.
SO I INTO A BIG POTAWATOMI AGAIN
IN I THINK INTRIGUED OUT OF WHAT
WHICH WOULD BE MUCH MUCH CHEAPER
AND A. LOT EASIER OF FOR TALK
CARE CENTERS TO MAINTAIN AND
OPERATE THE AND ON NEWLY OPENED.
NUMBER ONE THING THAT THE BILL
SPECIFICALLY ARM.
DEFERS TO THE DEPARTMENT SOCIAL
SERVICES AND THE WATER BOARD TO
DEVELOP.
DECIDE HOW IT'S GOING TO BE THAT
THAT CHILDHOOD LEAD TESTING
REQUIREMENT WILL BE CARRIED OUT.
BECAUSE THERE ARE ALL THESE
SPECIFIC CONCERNS AMONG
STAKEHOLDERS AS TO HOW IT'LL
HAPPEN.
AND WE FELT THAT IT WAS BEST TO.
TO LEAVE THAT DECISION MAKING UP
TO THE AGENCIES.
WHO KNOW BEST REALLY HOW TO DO?
THE MOST EFFICIENT WATER
TESTING AND THIS AND THIS WAY IN
THIS WAY FOR THESE FACILITIES
ONE THING TO POINT OUT IS THAT
CHILDCARE CENTERS RIGHT NOW
ESPECIALLY IF THERE'S OWN
COMMERCIAL. THERE IS NO TAP
WATER TESTING OF THOSE CENTERS
ON THERE IS SPORADIC TESTING OF
HOMES THEIR STUDENT LEAD AND
COPPER RULE.
ENFORCEMENT BUT.
THEY'RE BASICALLY OFF THE GRID
IN TERMS OF WATER TESTING FROM
INSIDE THE FACILITIES RIGHT NOW
SO THAT IS WHY. WE FEEL LIKE
THIS IS A PRETTY URGENT MATTER
TO BRING FORWARD.
SO WHAT'S GOING ON NINE TO TALK
THIS OUT LEFT LEVEL OF A CHILD
CARE LICENSING HOSPITALS ARE
SERVICES THAT WOULD PULL OUT OUR
EVERY EVERY. ONCE IN EVERY SIX
YEARS WE HAVE THE BILL
SPECIFICALLY SAYS ONE AT LEAST
EVERY FIVE YEARS AFTER THE
INITIAL ROUND OF TESTING BUT. IT
LEAVES OPEN.
.
IT LEAVES OUT OPEN TO THE
AGENCY'S DECIDE HOW TO BEST
PROCEED.
NOW IS THERE ANY DESIRE THAT NO
AFFECT AND.
.
A MAN DEL REQUIREMENT THE WHAT
ABOUT DRINKING WATER SUPPLY
RATHER THAN TAP WATER JUST A
FIXED TERRA.
WOULD A FIXTURE. A SHALL MEET
THAT REQUIREMENT THAT.
I MEAN.
DID THE WATER PIPE BY OPERATION
IF THE BIDDING HAPPENS TO BE OLD
ONE THAT CAN BE A LOT COSTA DEBT
THAN.
IN A BIG WATER BOTTLE THAT
EVERYBODY CAN DRINK OUT ABOUT
WHAT WAS SOME OF THE OPTIONS
THAT WOULD BE AVAILABLE TO
CENTER WOULD BE FOR INSTANCE A
FILTER BECAUSE FILTERS CAN.
FILTER OUT LEAD FAIRLY EASILY.
.
AND AGAIN THAT'S PART.
THE THE REQUIREMENT WOULD BE
THAT THE CHILDREN HAVE TO BE
PROVIDED SAFE IMPOSSIBLE AND
LEAD FREE WATER.
AND SO IF THERE HAS TO BE STOP
GAP MEASURES AVAILABLE TO THE
CHILDCARE FACILITIES CHILD CARE
CENTERS.
THEN THAT WOULD OBVIOUSLY THAT
WOULD BE SOMETHING THAT THE
AGENCIES COULD.
COULD INCLUDE IN THE REGULATION.
YEAH AVAILABLE OPTION THAT HALL
AVAILABLE LOOK A LOWER COST
AVAILABLE OPTION IF THERE'S A
PLUMBING PROBLEM MORE EXPENSIVE
PROBLEM THEN THAT WOULD BE A
STOP GAP.
OPTION.
THERE IS ALSO ON THIS AVAILABLE
FUND THAT WE MADE AVAILABLE FOR
THE FACILITIES TO USED UP TO.
ARM.
TO EMPLOYEE TO.
UPGRADE THEIR DRINKING WATER
SYSTEMS OF THAT'S WHAT THEY NEED
IF THAT'S IF THAT IF THEY CAN
DEMONSTRATE AND THE AS THEY
WOULD PROVIDE THAT THE. SURE
KNOW THE.
THERE IS EXIT THERE'S AN
EXISTING POT OF MONEY THAT HAS
NOT BEEN UTILIZED IT'S FOR
CHILDCARE FACILITIES TO USE TO
UPGRADE.
THEIR FACILITIES AND THIS WOULD
SPECIFIC SPECIFIED THAT THE
CENTERS CAN USE THAT NO INTEREST
LOAN PROGRAM.
TO PAY FOR THEIR UPGRADES.
IT WOULD BE ALONE IT'S A LOAN.
ONLY MY CONCERN IS THAT. BECAUSE
OF THEIR WELL WE ALL KNOW THAT
THAT THERE IS A SHORTAGE UP
ATTACK GET CENTER SO. AWESOME
AND AND AND AND I DON'T BURDEN
BECAUSE HER REGULATIONS HAVE%
WATER ORDERS JUST SO IN AWE
CREATE HUMBLE PROBLEMS.
OUR OBJECT THANK YOU THANK YOU
ANY OTHER COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
I WOULD LIKE TO.
THANK YOU ON THIS AYE. MEASURE
OF PIETY A CO AUTHORED A BILL
LAST YEAR FOR LEAD TESTING IN
SCHOOLS ARE BECAUSE WE SAW A
PROBLEM IN SAN DIEGO AND SO I
REALLY APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING
THIS ARM FORWARD.
AND JUST KIND OF TO PIGGYBACK
ON THAT I DID SPENT YEARS ON A
WATER DISTRICT AND UPON REQUEST
IF ANY AGENCY OR ANY HOUSEHOLD
FOR THAT MATTER I REQUEST A
TESTING THEY THEY COULD COME UP
AND DO IT FOR FREE.
SO WE CAN ADD THAT TO TO THE
AVAILABLE OPTIONS AS WELL SO I
THINK YOU ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
COULD I ADD ONE MORE THING.
IN THE TWO YEARS SINCE FLINT
HAS HAPPENED WE HAVE LEARNED SO
MUCH MORE ABOUT HOW LED GETS
INTO WATER AND THAT THE
MAGNITUDE OF. WE'RE STARTING TO
LEARN ABOUT THE MAGNITUDE OF THE
PROBLEM THROUGH THESE TESTING
PROGRAMS.
BUT WE ARE ALSO STARTING TO
LEARN SO MUCH MORE ABOUT HOW TO
DEAL WITH IT.
AND SO CALIFORNIA WILL BE THE
BENEFICIARY OF LEARNING FROM
OTHER STATES AS THE.
ALL WATER RESOURCE CONTROL BOARD
AND DSS WORK TOGETHER TO DEVELOP
THESE REGULATIONS.
THANK YOU I HAVE A MOTION BY.
MISTER STONE AND DOCTOR
ARAMBULA.
.
YES
I AND IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE.
WELL THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I I
THINK THAT WE PRETTY MUCH
COVERED.
OF THE EXTENT OF THE BILL AND
WHAT IT'S DESIGNED TO DO AND.
YOU KNOW I'VE I'VE SAID THIS
MANY TIMES HAVE YET TO SEE A
PERFECT BILL BUT I THINK THIS
ONE. MOVES IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION TO ADDRESS THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY OF OUR YOUNG PEOPLE
SO. AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
LEADERSHIP IN THE COMMITTEES.
RECOMMENDED AMENDMENTS AND WE.
LOOK WITHOUT I ASKED HER
RESPECTFULLY ASK HER ABOUT.
THANK YOU KICKING ME LOOK
REPUBLIC.
YES.
I DO BEST AMENDED TO THE
ENVIRONMENT SAFETY AND TOXIC
MATERIALS COMMITTEE.
RUBIO AYE REVEAL AYE CHOI.
CHOI I RECOLLECT BY BUT I'M GLAD
I MAIENSCHEIN.
GLASS.
STONE.
STONE AYE THURMOND.
THE BILL IS OUT FOR THIS YEAR
THANK YOU I WITHOUT OBJECTION I
WOULD LIKE TO HEAR AB SIXTEEN
NINETY FOUR BY MISTER STONE OUT
OF ORDER PLEASE. MISTER STONE
WOULD YOU LIKE TO PRESENT.
I AM THE VOTE FOR MISTER HOLDEN
SPELL WAS FOUR ZERO.
AND MOVES ONTO OUT.
ENVIRONMENTAL SAY SAFETY AND AND
TALK TO MAKE IT MATERIALS.
THANK YOU MISTER SOUTH THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND FOR INDULGING ME
ON THIS.
THIS IS AN URGENCY MATTER AND IF
WE CAN GET THIS MOVED FURTHER
QUICKLY TODAY THEN HOPEFULLY WE
CAN HEAR THIS ON THE FLOOR. AND
SOLVE A PROBLEM THAT DEVELOPED
IN A BEFORE.
FOR LAST YEAR.
A BEFORE FOUR WAS THE LATEST IN
THE SERIES OF BILLS TO.
WORK ON THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE CONTINUUM OF CARE REFORM.
AND WHAT HAPPENED WAS THERE WERE
SOME CHATTERING OUT AMENDMENTS
THAT WERE ADDED THE VERY AND
THEN IT TURNED OUT THAT WHAT
THOSE DID. WAS INTERFERE WITH AN
ONGOING CONVERSATION ABOUT.
PRIORITIES WITH CHILDCARE SLOTS
AND THE TALKED A LOT TO THE
ADVOCATES.
WHAT IF THAT TO DEPARTMENT
SOCIAL SERVICES AND OTHERS AND
WE FEEL THAT IT IS BEST TO JUST
REMOVE THAT LANGUAGE AND THAT'S
WHAT THIS BILL DOES REMOVE THAT
LANGUAGE SO WE DON'T INTERFERE?
WITH THE ONGOING CONVERSATION
ABOUT PRIORITIES.
AND HOW WE END UP WITH
PRIORITIES READ CHILD CARE SLOTS
IS IS A DIFFERENT CONVERSATION
THIS WAS NOT INTENDED TO WAIT IN
IN THAT FIGHT. SO WHAT THIS BILL
DOES IS REMOVE THAT LANGUAGE
KIND OF RESETS TO THE TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN LANGUAGE
THAT'S WHY ITS URGENCY WE'VE
MOVE THIS THROUGH QUICKLY
THROUGH THE. SENATE I'M HOPING
FOR AN AYE VOTE TODAY AND WE CAN
GET THIS PROBLEM SOLVED AND ASK
YOUR RIVAL.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
CAN ANYONE IS IN OPPOSITION.
K. HEARING THEN I'LL BRING IT UP
TO THE COMMITTEE.
OKAY I'M GOING TO MOVE THE BELL.
THANK YOU.
A SECOND OR.
I WOULD MAKE THE MOTION ITSELF
I'M.
THANK YOU I ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
WE DON'T HAPPEN CAN YOU BECAUSE
OF THE TRUTH.
THANK YOU.
RUBIO AYE
REVEAL AYE DOCTOR CHOI.
DOCTOR CHOI AYE DOWN BELOW.
MAIENSCHEIN.
THERE'S
STONE.
STONE AYE THURMOND.
WE NEED BILLS BUT THREE ZERO WE
NEED ONE MORE. WE UP THREE ZERO
WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR
FRENCH.
AND THE.
MOTION WAS.
TO CONCURRENT SENATE AMENDMENTS
AND RE REFER TO THE ASSEMBLY
FLOOR.
MISTER FLORA.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS
IT'S A PRIVILEGE TO PRESENT
TODAY.
AB NINETEEN FOURTEEN I WILL
START BY SAYING THANK YOU TO THE
COMMITTEE AND YOUR STAFF'S WORK
CAN WE ACCEPT YOUR AMENDMENT SO
I PERSONALLY HARD WORK AND
MOVING THIS BILL FORWARD. AB
NINETEEN FORTY WOULD FULFILL A
RECOMMENDATION FROM THE STATE
AUDITOR TO THE LEGISLATOR. BY
ADDING SIX SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR
CRIMES.
TO THE DEPARTMENT SOCIAL
SERVICES CAREGIVER BACKGROUND
CHECK BUREAUS NON EXEMPT LIST.
THE STATE AUDITOR'S
RECOMMENDATION TO THE
LEGISLATIVE EXPANDS A LIST OF
PRIVATE CRIMES TO INCLUDE SIX
SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR CRIMES TO
THOSE. ALREADY ON THE NON EXEMPT
THOSE SIX CRIMES INCLUDING THREE
OUNCES OF RAPE PIMPING
PANDERING.
AND IDENTITY THEFT
DSS OPERATES OVER SEVEN THOUSAND
COMMUNITY CARE FACILITIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA INCLUDING CHILD CARE
FACILITIES FOSTER. FAMILY HOMES
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY
FACILITIES AN ELDERLY FISTS
FACILITIES.
PROTECT OUR CLIENTS THE STATE
REQUIRES ALL APPLICANTS TO
OBTAIN A BACKGROUND CHECK FOR
THE CARE GIVERS BACKGROUND CHECK
BUREAU.
THE STATE OUT OF OTHER
DISCOVERED THAT BETWEEN TWO
THOUSAND AND. THIRTEEN AND TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN THE DSS
RECEIVED SIX HUNDRED BACKGROUND
CHECKS MENTION ONE OF THE SIX
CRIMES MENTIONED AND AB NINETEEN
FOURTEEN.
DURING THAT SAME TIME FRAME THIS
C. B. C. B.. ALLOWED FORTY OF
THOSE SIX HUNDRED INDIVIDUALS TO
WORK IN A LICENSE CARE FACILITY
IN OTHER WORDS BETWEEN TWO
THOUSAND THIRTEEN.
AND TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN FORTY
INDIVIDUALS PREVIOUSLY CONVICTED
OF EITHER RATE PIMPING PANDERING
OR IDENTITY THEFT WERE ALLOWED
TO WORK.
WITH SOME OF OUR MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS.
AB NINETEEN FOURTEEN WOULD
ALLOW.
WOULD ADD SIX SUBSTANTIALLY
SIMILAR CRIMES TO THE NON EXEMPT
LIST
ENSURING THAT WE PROTECT THE
MOST VULNERABLE TO VIGILS. IN
OUR SOCIETY HERE TO TESTIFY WITH
ME IN SUPPORT OF THE STATE
AUDITOR'S REPORT IS BOB HARRIS
FROM THE CALIFORNIA STATE
AUDITOR'S OFFICE.
AND CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND MY NAME IS BOB
PARIS WITH THE STATE AUDITOR'S
OFFICE AND I WAS THE PRINCIPAL
AUDITOR ON AN AUDIT WE CONDUCTED
OF THE CARE GIVER BACKGROUND
CHECKS BUREAU WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
ON AS A MATTER OF POLICY OUR
OFFICE DOESN'T TAKE A POSITION
EITHER AGAINST OR FOR
LEGISLATION BUT I CAN TESTIFY
THAT THIS BILL AS DRAFTED IN
WITH THE COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS
WOULD IMPLEMENT OUR
RECOMMENDATION WE MADE. IN THAT
AUDIT REPORT SPECIFICALLY TO
EXPAND THE LIST OF NON EXAMPLE
CRIMES CURRENTLY IN STATE LAW.
AND BY WAY OF BACKGROUND AS A
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER ID
MENTIONED.
STATEWIDE GENERALLY PROHIBITS
ANYONE WITH A CRIMINAL
CONVICTION FROM BEING PRESENT TO
CARE FOR LIVE WITH CLIENTS
UNLICENSED CARE FACILITIES BUT
IT ALSO PROVIDES THE DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES THE ABILITY
TO ISSUE EXEMPTIONS TO THAT
PROHIBITION.
EXCEPT FOR A AND NUMERATOR
NUMBER OF CRIMES WHICH WERE
CONSIDERED NON EXEMPT APPLE
ANOTHER IT'S THE DEPARTMENT
CAN'T ISSUE PERMISSION TO BE IN
THE FACILITY.
DURING THE AUDIT WE FOUND THAT
THERE WERE SEVERAL CRIMES
INCLUDED IN THIS BILL THAT WERE
SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR TO CRIMES
ON THAT NON EXEMPT HERBALIST BUT
THE DEPARTMENT WAS CURRENTLY IN
IS STILL CURRENTLY ALLOWED ISSUE
EXEMPTIONS FOR THOSE CRIMES DOES
INCLUDE. OFFENSES FOR SEXUAL
ASSAULT AND IDENTITY THEFT.
IN PARTICULAR WE FOUND ONE
EXAMPLE WHERE EH INDIVIDUAL WHO
WAS CONVICTED CONVICTED OF
IDENTITY THEFT WAS LATER
CERTIFIED TO BE AN ADMINISTRATOR
FOR RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITY
FOR THE ELDERLY. NOW AN
INDIVIDUAL WHO WAS CONVICTED OF
ELDER ABUSE BECAUSE THEY STEAL
THE IDENTITY OF AN ELDER A
INDIVIDUAL. WOULD NOT BE ALLOWED
IN ONE OF THOSE FACILITIES BUT
BECAUSE THIS GENERAL CRIME OF
IDENTITY THEFT IS NOT CURRENTLY
INCLUDED ON THE LIST THAT
INDIVIDUAL WAS NOT ALLOWED TO BE
PRESENT IN SUCH A FACILITY.
AND I'M HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS THAT THE COMMITTEE
MIGHT HAVE.
OKAY AND ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS RICKROLLING
TRIPS IN THE ASSOCIATION
REGIONAL CENTERS AGENCIES AND
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
INTEREST ANDERSON WITH ARKIN UCP
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATION AND
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
OKAY.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
AFTERNOON AND CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE LIZZIE BEACON WITH
THE ACLU CALIFORNIA AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO THE
SPELL. OF THIS BILL WOULD EXPAND
THE CATEGORY OF PEOPLE WHO ARE.
WHO HAVE A LIFETIME PROHIBITION
AGAINST BEING PRESIDENT ONE OF
THESE FACILITIES EVEN IF THEY
POSE NO RISK TO THE HEALTH OR
SAFETY? I'M MORE WELL BEING OF
THE OF THE CLIENTS
AND WE RECOGNIZE THAT THIS THAT
THESE ARE VULNERABLE POPULATIONS
AND THAT'S WHY AS WE'VE HEARD.
DSS IS REQUIRED TO DO BACKGROUND
CHECKS ON ANY YOU ON ANYONE WHO
WOULD WANT TO BE PRESENT WHEN
THESEFACILITIES. ANYONE WITH A
CONVICTION AYE IS PROHIBITED
FROM BEING AT THESE FACILITIES
UNLESS THEY GET THE EXEMPTION
FROM THE CBC BE.
THE CBC. THE CAREGIVERS
BACKGROUND CHECK BUREAU.
REVIEWS THE FULL CONVICTION
HISTORY OF OF THESE INDIVIDUALS
AND THEY CONSIDER STATEMENTS OF
CHARACTER AND THEY CONSIDER THE
VULNERABILITY OF THE VICTIMS OF
THE PRIOR OFFENSES. AYE THEY
THEY CONSIDER THE FULL POLICE
REPORTS OF ALL OF THE INCIDENTS
THE INDIVIDUALS STATEMENTS OF OF
ALL OF THE OFFENSES THERE'S A
THOROUGH PROCESS FOR.
FOR INDIVIDUALLY VETTING THESE
PEOPLE ON WITH CREEK WITHOUT A
CONVICTION HISTORIES AND IT IS
ONLY IF THEY ARE ABLE TO PROVIDE
SUBSTANTIAL AND CONVINCING
EVIDENCE. THAT THEY ARE OF GOOD
CHARACTER AND THAT THEY ARE NOT
A THREAT TO THE SAFETY OR WELL
BEING OF THE CLIENTS THAT THEY
CAN BE GRANTED AN EXEMPTION. SO
THERE IS A PROCESS AND IN PLACE
FOR CAREFULLY EVALUATING THESE
INDIVIDUALS AYE THIS BILL WOULD
COMPLETELY LOCKED OUT. AND AB A
LOCK OUT A NUMBER OF PEOPLE FROM
THIS.
FROM THIS ENTIRE PROCESS BY
ENACTING THIS LIFETIME
PROHIBITION AGAINST ANYONE WHO
HAS EVER HAD ANY OF THESE
CONVICTIONS I'M FROM EVER BEING
PRESIDENT ONE OF THESE
FACILITIES. EVEN IF THEY ARE OF
NO THREAT TO THE SAFETY AND WELL
BEING OF THESE CLIENTS AT
THERE'S NO EVIDENCE THAT THIS
BILL ACTUALLY WOULD IMPROVE THE
SAFETY AND WELL BEING OF THE
CLIENTS. AND.
I HAVEN'T HEARD ANY EVIDENCE
THAT ANY OF THE INDIVIDUALS WITH
THESE CONVICTIONS WHO HAVE BEEN
ALLOWED ADD TO BE PRESENT AT
THESE FACILITIES HAVE BEEN
INVOLVED IN ANYTHING THAT
RESULTED IN HARM TO ANYONE WHO'S
AT THESE FACILITIES.
SITTING AROUND BUT WHAT WE DO
KNOW IS THAT THIS BILL WOULD
DISCRIMINATE AGAINST PEOPLE WITH
CONVICTION HAS STORIES AND MAKES
IT MORE DIFFICULT FOR THEM TO
FIND EMPLOYMENT FOR THEM TO. AND
FIND STABLE HOUSING FOR THEM TO
FIND VOLUNTEER OPPORTUNITIES
EVEN AND SO FOR FOR THESE
REASONS WE ARE OPPOSED.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
I'M HEARING A NEW GOAL MADE ME
CLOSE PLEASE APOLOGIZE Y. THINK
THAT THE CHAIR AND YOUR STAFF
FOR YOUR AMENDMENTS TO THIS BILL
AND WE OBSCENE EXCEPT THOSE
AMENDMENTS ARE WRITTEN. SPEC
LAST RIVAL.
I THINK I NEED A MOTION AND A
SECOND.
I'LL GO AND MOVE.
OKAY AND I HAVE.
.
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
CAN YOU CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
RUBIO.
RUBIO I DOCTOR CHOI AYE DOCTOR
CHOI I AND NUMBER LEFT.
MAIENSCHEIN.
DRESSED.
STONE.
STONE AYE THURMOND.
BECAUSE THREE VOTES TO SIERRA
WHO EACH ONE THANK YOU WHICH YOU
HAVE A THREE ZERO WORLD HOLD IT
OPEN UNTIL WE.
HAVE OTHER MEMBERS THAT CAN.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER COSTS
ON
.
I'M SORRY.
OKAY WITH MR GIVES THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHO WAS
HERS THANK YOU.
WE'RE TRYING TO FIGURE IT OUT.
BUT AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I WOULD LIKE TO START
OFF BY SAYING I ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
WHICH FURTHER CLARIFY DEFINES
THE.
AND DEVISES VIOS BILL LANGUAGE
AND THANK THE CHAIR AND THE
STAFF FOR WORKING TO WORKING
WITH US TO IMPROVE THIS BILL.
I'M HERE TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY TWO FORTY SEVEN
WHICH SEEKS TO ENSURE FOSTER YOU
HAVE A CONSISTENT AND STRONG
HOME FOUNDATION. AND ARE NOT
UNNECESSARILY MOVED OF FROM ONE
PLACE TO ANOTHER ACCORDING TO
THE.
CHILD WELFARE INDICATOR PROJECT
THE NATION'S AVERAGE IS FOUR
POINT EIGHTEEN PLACEMENT CHANGES
PER ONE THOUSAND DAYS.
IN CARE OF A FOR FOSTER YOUTH
WE HARM OUR CHILDREN AND DISRUPT
THEIR HEALTH AND WELL BEING BY
MOVING THEM AMONGST HOME TO HOME
TO HOME.
THESE YOU HAVE TO CHANGE SCHOOLS
ARM AND RISK A DESTABILIZE
DESTABILIZING ON THEIR
RELATIONSHIPS.
THEY HAVE BUILT UP IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES.%
THIS BILL THIS IS THE REASON WHY
THIS BILL IS IMPORTANT ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY TO FORTY SEVEN WILL
CREATE A PROCESS FOR PLACEMENT.
STRANGERS AND REQUIRE SOCIAL
WORKERS AND PLACEMENT AGENCIES
TO CREATE A PLAN WITH FACILITATE
MEDIATE AND CONFLICT RESOLUTION
PRACTICES.
SO THAT IF A PARENT HAS A
CONCERN RATHER THAN MERELY
REQUESTING THE CHILD BE REMOVED.
IT.
QUIRK CHOIRS A CONVERSATION TO
TAKE PLACE IN AND TOO QUICK TO
HELP RESOLVE ANY OUTSTANDING
ISSUES OF THEIR THIS BILL ALSO
REQUIRES A FIFTEEN DAY NOTICE
BEFORE A CHILD CAN BE REMOVED.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT IF
IT IS DETERMINED THAT A YOUTH
HEALTH AND WELL BEING IS IN
JEOPARDY.
WITH THEIR CURRENT PLACEMENT
THE FIFTEEN DAY NOTICE IS WAIVED
AND THE PLACEMENT TRAINS FOLLOWS
THE CURRENT STANDARD SO IT CAN.
.
BE THE TALK OF REMOVED.
IMMEDIATELY IN THE BEST
INTERESTS OF THAT CHILD.
WE HAVE TO KEEP FAMILIES
TOGETHER THAT WANTS TO STAY
TOGETHER AND WE CERTAINLY
WOULDN'T KICK OUT OUR OWN
BIOLOGICAL CHILD BECAUSE OF A
MINOR.
DISRUPTION AND THAT MAY TAKE
PLACE ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TO
FORTY SEVEN IS A SAFE AND
THOUGHTFUL A BILL DEVELOPED BY
FOSTER YOUTH THAT SUPPORT FOSTER
YOUTH. WHO HAS ALREADY BEEN
THROUGH ENOUGH?
HERE WITH ME TO PROVIDE
SUPPORTING TESTIMONIES MISS
VANESSA I'M HERNANDEZ OF THE
DIRECTOR OF THE STATE WHY POLICY
FOR THE CALIFORNIA YOU
CONNECTION.
AND.
CAN
KATERINA CAT AGREEMENT CATERINA
A MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA YOUTH
CONNECTION.
WE JUST STEP IN AND MAKE A TIME
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON I'M MY
NAME SO THAT'S A HERNANDEZ I'M
WITH C. WAY SEE WE ARE A YOU
PLED ORGANIZATION AND THAT MEANS
THAT OUR YOUNG PEOPLE COME
TOGETHER ANNUALLY TO DETERMINE.
THE BIGGEST GAPS IN THE CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM I'M BASED ON
THEIR OWN ANALYSIS THEIR
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE
AND.
MOST DEPRESSED IMPRESSIVELY
SLIP THE SO THEY IDENTIFIED THE
SOLUTIONS TO THESE.
THIS YEAR WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A
POTENTIAL PLATFORM.
MEMBERS REALLY CHALLENGE
THEMSELVES TO GET AT THE ROOT
CAUSES OF SOME OF THESE MOST
NEGATIVE OUTCOMES THAT WE'VE ALL
WE ARE ALL VERY FAMILIAR WITH.
THIS YEAR.
OUR MEMBERS ARE LOOKING TO
RAISE THE FLAG AND THE
IMPORTANCE OF STABILITY
STABILITY EMPLACEMENTS STABILITY
IN RELATIONSHIPS A STABILITY IN
SERVICES AND STABILITY IN THE
WILDNESS.
CURRENTLY THE CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM EMPLOYS A TOOL CALLED THE
SEVEN DAY NOTICES
THIS IS NOT IN REGULATIONS AND
SAW ENCODE AND IT THE SENTENCE I
GOT SEVEN DADE IS SOME A FULL
SENTENCE THAT OUR YOUNG PEOPLE.
CAN COMPREHEND AND USE IN
SHORTHAND SEVEN DAY NOTICE IS
THE FORMAL PROCESS IN WHICH A
COUNTY FOSTER PARENT OR SOCIAL
WORKERS. USES TO INITIATE A
POLICEMAN CHANGE IMAGINE
UPROOTING YOUR WHOLE LIFE.
IN LESS THAN SEVEN DAYS.
AB TWO TWO FOUR SEVEN WILL DO
THE FOLLOWING THINGS IT WILL A
DEFYING ABRUPTLY SPIN CHANGES
THIS BILL WILL ALSO.
OUTLINED THOUGH CORRECT PROCESS
THAT IF A POLICEMAN CHANGE HAS
TO OCCUR AND WE UNDERSTAND SOME
CASES THAT DOES.
THE FOLLOWING PROCESS IT SHOULD
HAPPEN AND ALSO OUTLINE.
PARAMETERS OF IT IF AND WHEN HOW
A PLACEMENT CHANGE SHOULD NEVER
OCCUR I  IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE NIGHT I'M DURING A SCHOOL
DAY OR WHERE IT RESULTS AND.
SIBLING SETS BEING PULLED APART.
I AM I WILL NOW PASS IT TO MY
COLLEAGUE CUTTING.
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS CUTTING I
CAME BACK I AM TWENTY TWO YEARS
OLD FROM OAKLAND CALIFORNIA AND
I AM THE MSW STUDENT AT UC
BERKELEY. I AM ALSO A MEMBER OF
THE STATEWIDE LEGISLATIVE
COMMITTEE OF CALIFORNIA YOUTH
CONNECTION.
I AM SPEAKING IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY TO FORTY SEVEN THIS
BILL SEEKS TO CREATE A YOUTH
CENTERED PROCESS FOR STABILITY
WITHIN THE CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM.
I FIRST ENTERED FOSTER CARE WHEN
I WAS JUST SIX MONTHS OLD AN
EMANCIPATED AT EIGHTEEN. DURING
THIS TIME I EXPERIENCED THIRTY
TWO PLACEMENT CHANGES.
I WAS PULLED FROM HOMES IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT. AND OUT OF
SCHOOL IN THE MIDDLE OF THE DAY.
I SPECIFICALLY REMEMBER ONE TIME
WHEN I WAS CALLED TO THE OFFICE
AND MY SOCIAL WORKER IS THERE
SHE'D ALREADY PACKED A TRASH BAG
WITH THE THINGS THAT SHE THOUGHT
WERE MOST IMPORTANT FOR ME TO
BRING AND TOLD ME THAT I WAS.
MOVING SOMEWHERE ELSE AND AT
MOVING TO SACRAMENTO FROM
OAKLAND AND.
UNFORTUNATELY WASN'T ABLE TO
KEEP TOUCH WITH MY SIBLINGS.
I WAS IN SECOND GRADE.
THE THING ABOUT PACKING AND
TRASH BAGS OF THAT TRASH BAGS
ARE TOO FRAGILE TO CARRY
FUTURES.
THIS BILL.
IS THE THIRTY STRUCTURE THAT WE
DESERVE TO PROTECT OUR FUTURES.
AB TWENTY TO FORTY SEVEN MATTERS
BECAUSE STABILITY BE GET
SUCCESS.
I LIKE USING PLANTS AS A
METAPHOR.
BECAUSE YOU CAN BE PLANTED PLANT
AND I CAN BE TRANSPLANTED EGGMAN
GROW BEAUTIFULLY BUT THERE'S A
PROCESS.
IN ORDER FOR IT TO FLOURISH IF
YOU DON'T WATER IT IF YOU DON'T
TAKE CARE THAT IF YOU DON'T
ALLOW TIME TO ROUTE. THEN IT
WILL NEVER GROW.
I JUST ASK THAT.
WITH SUPPORTING THIS BILL THAT
YOU GIVE.
FOSTER YOUTH THAT PROCESS.
BECAUSE WE SHOULD HAVE A SYSTEM
THAT PEOPLE WOULD BE OKAY WITH
THEIR KIDS BEING AND BUT
UNFORTUNATELY IT'S A SYSTEM THAT
PEOPLE ARE AFRAID ADDS.
I SUPPORT THIS BILL BECAUSE I
DON'T WANT ANY FOSTER YOUTH TO
GO THROUGH WHAT I HAD TO GO
THROUGH I STILL DON'T UNPACK MY
BELONGINGS IN THAT SENSE OF
INSTABILITY STILL STICKS WITH ME
YEARS LATER NO MATTER HOW MUCH.
I ACHIEVE OR TRY.
INSTEAD OF SEVEN DAY NOTICE SAYS
INSTEAD OF TRASH BAGS WE NEED
THIS BELL.
STRUCTURE FOR STABILITY IS IN
YOUR HANDS AND I REALLY ASK THAT
YOU SUPPORT THAT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME I URGE
YOUR AYE VOTE ON AB TWENTY TO
FORTY SEVEN TO CREATE A YOUTH
CENTERED PROCESS FOR STABILITY
WITHIN THE FOSTER. CARE SYSTEM
FOR THE FUTURE. OF THE YOUNG
PEOPLE THAT WE SERVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES AND AS
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M KELLY BROOKS
I'M REPRESENTING THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
TODAY AND WE HAVE A SUPPORT IN
CONCEPT POSITION WE WANT I THINK
THE AUTHOR AND THE CALIFORNIA
YOUTH CONNECTION. IN ENGAGING
WITH US SO EARLY ON THE SPELL
AND WE AGREE THAT PRESERVING
PLACEMENTS WHERE EVER POSSIBLE
IS MUCH PREFERRED OVER MAKING
PLACEMENT CHANGES AND THAT AN
ORDERLY WAY. OF MAKING PLACEMENT
CHANGES IS WHAT WE WANT TO IS
THAT YOU WANNA UP.
MOVE HAS TO OCCUR.
WE THINK THE BILL HAS MERIT AND
WE'RE WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR ON
THE SPONSORS ON SOME POTENTIAL
CHANGES THAT WOULD ALLOW US TO
MOVE TURN OUT RIGHT SUPPORT
POSITION. AND WE THINK EVERYONE
AROUND THE TABLE IS COMMITTED
HOME TO WORKING TOGETHER AND
WE'RE COMFORTABLE WITH MOVING
THE BILL FORWARD TODAY THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
HELLO JULIE MCCORMICK FOR THE
CHILDREN'S LAW CENTER OF
CALIFORNIA ON BEHALF THE THIRTY
THREE THOUSAND CHILDREN WE SERVE
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
SELENA PRIOR WITH ASCII YOU
CALIFORNIA AND WE. HAVE SOME
CONCERNS WITH THE BILL BUT WE
UNDERSTAND THE INTENT AND WERE
ON WE LOOK FOR TO WORKING WITH
AUTHORED AND SPONSORED.
THANK YOU.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU BEFORE WE CONTINUE
WOULD LIKE TO ABSENCE I HAVE ALL
OF OUR MEMBERS HERE FREAKING TO
SOMETHING THAT PLEASE WE NEED A
VOTE ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
PLEASE.
ACTUALLY YOU KNOW WHAT.
LET'S FINISH
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE AMEND
OVERFLOWING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WAS CERTAINLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE BUT CERTAINLY I WANT TO
THANK. MY.
COLLEAGUE HERE NEXT TO ME FOR
DOING AN AMAZING JOB.
BECAUSE AS SHE SAID YOU CANNOT
PUT THEIR YOU KNOW THEIR LIVES
IN A TRASH BAG AND JUST TRY TO
MOVE OUT THAT. STICKS OUT IN MY
HEAD.
MORE VIVIDLY IN STRONG AND SO
WE ASKING FOR AN OPPORTUNITY TO
CREATE SOME STABILIZATION IN
THESE YOUNG PEOPLE'S LIVES
BECAUSE.
ALSO YOU THAT'S GONE THROUGH
TRAUMATIC EXPERIENCES BECAUSE
THEIR BOSS TO YOU. AND SO IT'S A
LOT I BELIEVE IS OUR JOB TO
CREATE SOME KIND OF NORMAL
NORMALCY AND WITHIN THEIR LIVES
NOT THINK THIS BILL DOES A SAGA
STRICTLY* WHEN I VOTE.
THANK YOU JUST FOR CLARIFICATION
YOU'RE ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS ABSOLUTELY BUT YOU
THAT BEGINNING YES THANK YOU
THANK YOU I AM A MOTION.
BY DOCTOR ARAMBULA HAS TAKEN BY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GOMEZ.
CAN YOU CALL THE BILL PLEASE.
RUBIO AYE REVEAL AYE DUTCH AYE
CHOI.
DOCTOR CHOI ITEM LEFT.
ARAMBULA I MAIENSCHEIN.
THERE'S.
THERE'S AYE STONE.
STONE AYE THURMOND.
THE BILL SCOTT SIX.
FIVE.
BUDGET.
WHO BUILT IT WE HAVE A OF FIVE
ZERO AND IT MOVES TO DO?
INSIGHTS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THINKING.
OKAY AND YES I HAVE TO OPEN THE
ROLE FOR AYE.
THE BILL.
I AND. I DON'T FOURTEEN.
I DIVERT FOURTEEN AB SIXTY
NINETY FOUR ASSEMBLY MEMBER MARK
STONE.
THAT WE CONCUR AND SENATE
AMENDMENTS AND RE REFER TO THE
FLOOR.
I'M GONNA.
ARAMBULA I. MAIENSCHEIN.
VARIOUS.
DRESS I.
THURMOND.
BILLS WE COULDN'T.
THANK YOU KATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CASA.
SORRY AND CAN THANK GOD.
YES. IT WAS MOVED BY A MISTER
STONE AND SECOND BY UP MISS
RAISES.
CONSENT CALENDAR AB EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
WEBER DO PASSED AMENDED TO THE
ASSEMBLY VETERANS AFFAIRS
COMMITTEE. ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB
TWENTY THIRTY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LOW MOAN. DO PASSED AMENDED TO
SIMPLY APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
A BEAST AT ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB
TWO IN TWENTY TO SIXTY NINE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY DO PASSED
TO THE ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
ITEM NUMBER NINE AB TWENTY THREE
THIRTEEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER MARK
STONE TO PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
ITEM NUMBER TEN AB TWENTY THREE
THIRTY SEVEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GIPSON DO PASSED THE ASSEMBLY
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE ITEM NUMBER
TWELVE AB TWENTY THREE NINETY
SEVEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER OBERNOLTE.
DO PASSED USUALLY HEALTH
COMMITTEE.
AND EIGHT ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN
ACR ONE SEVENTEEN THAT THE BILL
BE ADOPTED AND BE REFERRED TO
THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR ALL MY
CONSENT.
YOU CAN CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
RUBIO HIGH REVEAL AYE DOCTOR
CHOI.
DOCTOR CHOI I ARAMBULA. AND
NUMBER LIKE I MAIENSCHEIN.
GRACE.
THERE'S AYE.
STONE.
STONE AYE THURMOND.
FLAGSHIP.
TAKE ITS ACCOUNT CAN CONSENT
CALENDAR PASSES OF THE FIVE ZERO
VOTE OUT THANK YOU WILL GO AHEAD
AND MOVE ON TO.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER COST.
THIS TIME YES.
I DO APPRECIATE GOOD ACTORS.
THANK YOU MR ACOSTA
.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS
APPRECIATE THE TIME THIS
AFTERNOON.
DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES CURRENTLY SERVES OVER
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND CONSUMERS
WITH DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
THROUGH ITS COMMITTEE SERVICES
PROGRAM.
SERVICES ARE COORDINATED THROUGH
TWENTY ONE INDEPENDENT NONPROFIT
AGENCIES CALLED REGIONAL CENTERS
WHICH ACCESS ELIGIBILITY
ELIGIBILITY AND DEVELOP
INDIVIDUAL. PROGRAM PLANS FOR
CONSUMERS.
REGIONAL CENTERS* A CONTRACT
WITH TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
VENDORS AROUND THE STATE TO
PURCHASE SERVICES AND SUPPORT
FOR CONSUMERS.
DEPARTMENT PROVIDES THE REGIONAL
CENTERS WITH THE BUDGET FOR BOTH
THIRD MINISTRY OF OPERATIONS AND
THE PURCHASE OF SERVICES PREVENT
FROM VENDORS.
FOR RATES PREVIOUSLY NEGOTIATED
BETWEEN REGIONAL CENTERS AND
VENDORS BUDGET SOLUTIONS TAKEN
BY THE LEGISLATURE DURING THE
RECENT RECESSION FROZE RATES AND
ESTABLISH THE MEDIAN RATE
PROCESS FOR NEW VENDORS.
THERE IS A RATE CAP WAIVER
PROCESS FOR SITUATIONS WHEN A
LACK OF VENDOR AVAILABILITY
WITHIN THE CURRENT RATE
STRUCTURE COULD ADVERSELY IMPACT
THE HEALTH OR SAFETY OF THE
CONSUMER.
UNFORTUNATELY THE CURRENT
PROCESS IS OVERWHELMED RESULTING
IN EVER INCREASING WAIT TIMES
FOR WAIVER DETERMINATIONS.
A SIGNIFICANT FACTOR IN THE
CURRENT PROCESS BEING BOGGED
DOWN IS THAT REQUESTED BAR
INVOLVE LARGER SYSTEMIC ISSUE
ISSUES. LIKE LOCAL MINIMUM WAGE
ORDINANCES
WHICH ARE ROUTED THROUGH THE
EXISTING HEALTH AND SERVICE
WAIVER PROCESS.
ADDITIONALLY REGIONAL CENTERS
HAVE HAD A DIFFICULT TIME
TRACKING THE STATUS OF THE
WAIVER REQUESTS AFTER IS
SUBMITTED. TO DTS.
AB TWENTY TO FORTY FOUR WILL
ADDRESS THESE ISSUES BY ONE
CLARIFYING THAT EXISTING HEALTH
AND SAFETY WEBER PROCESSES.
IT'S FOR INDIVIDUAL ISSUES.
UP BUILDING ACCOUNTABILITY INTO
THE PROCESS TO ENSURE THAT THESE
INDIVIDUAL WAIVERS ARE ACTED
UPON AND REASONABLE TIME FRAMES.
AND THREE DIRECTING DTS TO
ESTABLISH A PROCESS FOR HANDLING
LARGER SYSTEMIC ISSUES.
ALL PARTIES INVOLVED INCLUDING
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA THE
REGIONAL CENTER PROVIDERS AND
CONSUMER GROUPS ALL OF
KNOWLEDGE.
SEVERITY OF THIS ISSUE AND
RECOGNIZE THAT SOMETHING NEEDS
TO BE DONE IMMEDIATELY.
I HAVE WITH ME IN SUPPORT EVELYN
ABOUT WHO SOUGHT. ABOLHASSAN
FROM DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA AND SHE'S GONNA BE
SPEAK LOUDLY FROM THE AUDIENCE
MY
YEAH DOT CORRECT.
AND.
RECURRENCE FROM THE ASSOCIATION
OF REGIONAL CENTER AGENCIES AND
BURIED YOUR ARE GIARDINI FROM.
THIS VILLAGE SERVICES SOCIAIS
XIN.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS EVELYN I WILL NOT
ATTEMPT TO LAST NAME. EVELYN
APPLE HASN'T DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA WERE ACROSS
DISABILITY ORGANIZATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL I
JUST WANNA MAKE A FEW COMMENTS
PER INDIVIDUALS ENTERING CRISIS.
OF THE CURTAIN THE CRIME PROCESS
DOESN'T WORK
WAITING LONG TIMES TO COME GO
THROUGH THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
WEBER PROCESS. OF ESSENTIALLY
PEOPLE AND UP INSTITUTIONALIZED
WHICH IS WHAT WE DON'T WANT SO
THAT WE'RE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL BECAUSE IT CREATES
TIMELINES. AN EXPEDITED PROCESS
FOR INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE IN
CRISIS AND ACCOUNTABILITY TO TO
MOVE THIS FORWARD SO WITH THAT
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE BILL WE.
LOOK FOR TO CONTINUE TO WORK ON
THE BILL AS THE BILL MOVES
THROUGH THE PROCESS AND. SEE
YOURSELF AS A RESOURCE BOTH TO
THE AUTHOR IN AND THE COMMITTEES
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS ARE COLLINS
WITH SUSPICION REGIONAL CENTER
AGENCIES I THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
A CARING THIS BILL ON THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY WAIVER PROCESS A IN
DTS IS A GOOD PROCESS. FOR WHAT
IT WAS INTENDED TO BE USED FOR
AND THAT IS ON AN INDIVIDUAL
BASIS.
TAKE GOOD CARE FOR FOLKS WHO
NEED THE HEALTH SAFETY WAIVER
PROCESS WHAT'S HAPPENED IS OVER
TIME IT'S BEEN THE ONLY PROCESS
THE DEPARTMENT'S BEEN ABLE TO
USE TO ADDRESS SYSTEMIC ISSUES
LIKE. THE LOCAL MINIMUM WAGE A
ISSUE. AND ARE WHAT'S HAPPENED
IS THE DEPARTMENT'S BEEN
OVERWHELMED WITH REQUESTS FROM
REGIONAL CENTERS THROUGH THEIR
PROVIDERS TO ADDRESS LOCAL
MINIMUM WAGE ANOTHER UNFUNDED
MANDATE PROGRAMS. SO WE SUPPORT
THIS.
THIS EFFORT TO LOOK FOR TO
CONTINUE TO WORK ITH THE AUTHOR
TO REFINE IT AND.
WE AND AND LARGE PARTIES
VARIOUS.
TIED TOGETHER WITH A AN EFFORT
BY MR HOLDEN THAT WAS. PROPER
FOR A CHAIRMAN ARAMBULA
SUBCOMMITTEE ON TRYING TO HARM
BRIDGE THE GAP ON FUNDING FOR OF
ON ON. UNMET TO NEED.
HAD UNFUNDED UNFUNDED MANDATES
A FOR OUR OUR PROVIDER COMMUNITY
ON A ONE TIME BASIS.
THANK YOU.
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR BURIED
CUTTING FOR THE CALIFORNIA
DISABILITY SERVICES ASSOCIATION
I'LL KEEP THIS QUITE BRIEF.
BUT OF FUNDAMENTALLY THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY WEBER PROCESS AT THE
MOMENT JUST DOESN'T WORK.
THE CURRENT WAIT TIME IF YOU
INCLUDE PENDING REQUESTS AS OF
DECEMBER TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
WAS A HUNDRED FIFTY SIX DAYS.
THAT'S NOT REASONABLE AMOUNT OF
TIME FOR INDIVIDUALS WEARING
CRISIS WHO WHOM AND PROVIDERS
WHO NEED RATES TO ACCOMMODATE
ADDITIONAL STAFFING FOR. A
MEDICAL BEHAVIORAL NEEDS I'M TO
WAIT IN ORDER TO GET SOME SORT
OF RATE RELIEF TO PROVIDE THOSE
NECESSARY SERVICES. ARE SO WE WE
ARE STRONGLY SUPPORT A SPELLING
WE HOPE FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
I'M SORRY IN SUPPORT.
AND I'M NOT OPPOSED TO.
I SAW THE PANIC BUTTON.
THANK YOU TERESA ANDERSON ON
BEHALF OF THE ARE CAN YOU SEE P.
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATES IN MARIN
STRONG SUPPORT WITHIN APPRECIATE
THE EFFORTS THEY AUTHORED THE
OFFICE.
THANK YOU.
OKAY NOW ANY MEMBER.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
QUE OUT BRING IT UP TO THE%
COMMITTEE. DOCTOR ARAMBULA.
POPE I HAVE A QUESTION TO THE
AUTHOR ON PAGE SIX OF THE
ANALYSIS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
AT THE VERY BOTTOM THERE'S A
QUESTION ABOUT. HOW THIS BILL
WILL INTERACT WITH THE CURRENT
RATE STUDY THAT THE DEPARTMENT
IS GOING THROUGH? AND WANTED TO
GET A COMMENT FROM YOU TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND WHAT EFFECT THIS
WOULD HAVE ON. THAT RATE STUDY.
WELL THE BILL ACTUALLY WOULDN'T
HAVE ANY EFFECT ON THE RATE
STUDY IF THE RATE STUDY COMES
OUT AND THERE'S A NEED AND
THERE'S AND THERE'S ACTUALLY
ACTION ON THE ON IT INCREASED
RATES. IT'S JUST GOING TO MAKE
IT THAT MUCH SIMPLER FOR THE
DEPARTMENT TO BE ABLE TO
IMPLEMENT BECAUSE THEY THE RATES
ARE GOING TO MINIMIZE THE NUMBER
OF REQUESTS THAT ARE COMING
THROUGH. AND AB AND BE THE FACT
THAT THEY'LL HAVE SOME SYSTEMS
IN PLACE BY THE TIME THAT RATE
STUDY IS COMPLETED WERE. GETTING
AHEAD OF A SERIOUS ISSUE RIGHT
NOW THAT IS REALLY IMPACTING THE
YET DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED
COMMUNITY.
AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
I'M THAT THE CONSUMERS ARE NOT
AFFECTED ADVERSELY.
AND THEN IF WE WAIT FOR THE
RATE STUDY WHICH IS GONNA TELL
US WHAT'S ALREADY PRETTY EVIDENT
IN THE IF IN THE ISSUE BUT A
WHAT THERE'S NO IN A CONFLICT
BETWEEN THE TWO AS A MATTER FACT
DIFFERENTLY COMPLEMENTARY. SO I
GUESS SOME.
.
I'M QUITE SUPPORTIVE OF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN'S
PROPOSAL TO CREATE A BANDAID TO
ALLOW US.
THIRD DO TIME TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE RATE STUDY COMES BACK AND
I'M. TRYING TO WONDER IF THIS
OBSCURES THE INFORMATION THAT
THEY'VE BEEN COLLECTING AND IS
THERE. ANYTHING WITHIN THIS BILL
THAT. WILL MAKE IT HARDER TO GET
AN ACCURATE ASSESSMENT OF WHAT'S
HAPPENING ON THE GROUND LEVEL I
I SHARE YOUR CONCERNS FOR MAKING
SURE THAT WE HAVE THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY WAIVERS IN A TIMELY
FASHION. I'M JUST WANTING TO
MAKE SURE WE GATHER APPROPRIATE
INFORMATION SO THAT WE CAN.
MAKE APPROPRIATE DECISIONS.
WELLED UP LET'S LET ME START BY
SAYING I DON'T BELIEVE THAT
THERE'S ANYTHING IN THE BILL
THAT WOULD BE YOU KNOW
DETRIMENTAL TO THAT PROCESS.
AND AND OF COURSE YOU KNOW
WE'RE WILLING TO WORK WITH ANY
YOU KNOW CONSTITUENCY GROUPS ARE
THE OF COURSE MISTER HOLDEN.
OUGHT TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
DOESN'T HAPPEN BUT YOU KNOW THAT
WE FEEL VERY STRONGLY THAT GOING
FORWARD WE CAN BE PROTECTING A
COMMUNITY. OTHER FRANKLY.
IN MY HUMBLE OPINION IS
UNDERSERVED AS IT IS AND WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY DON'T
FALL INTO FURTHER DEFICIT BUT
DOGMA CERTAINLY DON'T TO THINK
THAT ANYTHING THAT'S GOING TO
BE.
THE OF LIKE YOU SAID THE USER
WORKS GEAR THAT'S GOING TO BE
EXTREMELY YET THAT THE DATA THAT
WE'RE GONNA BE COLLECTING.
WITH THAT ASSURANCE THAT I MOVE
THE BILL.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. QUE I DO
HAVE AN ADDITIONAL COMMENT.
THAT DOT THE ONE CONCERN THAT I
DID HAVE IS.
WE HAVE.
WE CAN EXPEDITE THE APPROVAL
PROCESS BY DDS I'M COMING
REQUEST MULTIPLE EXTENSION SO
HOW WILL BE.
THAT BE.
AVOIDED OR IKE IF I'M DDS I CAN
EXTENDED YOU KNOW JUST HAVE SOME
VIA.
SITTING THERE TRYING TO EXTEND.
THE THE WAIVER SO. HOW?
CAN WE WORK AROUND THAT.
YOU WANT.
WE'RE.
WELL I CERTAINLY YOU KNOW THERE
THERE COULD BE A AN AMENDMENT TO
THE CAP THE NUMBER OF. YOU KNOW
OPPORTUNITIES FOR DDS TO MAKE
ADDITIONAL THIRTY DAY REQUESTS I
I DON'T KNOW IF THIS BUT THIS
POINT THE OTHERS INTERESTED IN
TAKING SUCH AN AMENDMENT BUT
THAT WOULD BE ONE WAY TO ENSURE.
I MEAN THE PROBLEM NOW IS THAT
THERE IS AN UNDEFINED AMOUNT OF
TIME THAT THEY CAN TAKE THE
NUMBER I REFERENCED EARLIER
DOESN'T EVEN TAKE INTO ACCOUNT
THE TIME REGIONAL CENTERS ARE
PROCESS IN THEIR QUEST THAT'S
JUST THE TIME. FROM WHICH DTS
FOR RECEIVES THE REQUEST AND
TRIES TO MAKE A DECISION ON IT
SO I THINK IT'S A GREAT FIRST
STEP IN AT LEAST PUTTING SOME
SORT OF TIME FRAME ON WHEN WE
WOULD EXPECT A DECISION TO BE
MADE BY DTS.
AND M. MADAM CHAIR ALSO KEEP IN
MIND THAT THIS BILL REALLY.
DRESSES TWO ISSUES ONE WE WANT
TO DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO MAKE
SURE THAT THOSE. TRUE HEALTH AND
SAFETY WAIVERS AT THIS.
PER OF THIS PROCESS WAS
ESTABLISHED TO. DO TAKES CARE OF
THE INDIVIDUALS THAT NEED THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY WAIVERS
APPROVED QUICKLY AND RIGHT NOW
IT'S HAPPINESS AT BEING SO
BOGGED DOWN IMPROVE A IN DEALING
WITH SYSTEM THE SYSTEMIC ISSUES
LIKE LOCAL MINIMUM WAGE. THAT'S
NOT HAPPENING SO THAT'S A REAL
PRIORITY OF THIS EFFORT AND AS
WELL TO COME UP WITH THE
ALTERNATIVE WAY TO DEAL WITH
THESE ISSUES LIKE ARM LOCAL
MINIMUM WAGE AND HAS DR ARAMBULA
MENTIONED. THIS BRIDGE FUNDING
FOR MISTER HOLDEN US REQUEST TO
THE BUDGET SUB ONE WILL GO A
LONG WAY TO HELP WITH THAT UNTIL
THE RACE THAT HE DOES COME OUT.
AND LEGISLATURE ACTS TO FULLY
FUND THE RATE STUDY.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS OKAY HIVE A MOTION AND
A SECOND. OF WHICH LIKE CLOSE.
BOB.
JUST.
WITHOUT ALL JUST ASK FOR YOUR UP
HERE I VOTE I THINK THAT WE'VE
COVERED A LOT OF GROUND.
THANK YOU.
CAN CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
RUBIO ARE REVEAL AYE DOCTOR CHOI
HIGH DOCTOR CHOI AYE SEPTEMBER
LEFT.
MAIENSCHEIN.
THERE'S.
VARIOUS AYE STONE.
STONE AYE THURMOND.
THE VILLAGE UP FOR THIS YEAR.
CAN'T WE HAVE A FOUR ZERO A VOTE
TO DO PET.
WHERE IT'S
THERE A MOTION WAS TO PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS
THANK
WELCOME AND THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR?
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS I COME
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE TO PRESENT
A. B. NINETEEN FIFTY SEVEN WHICH
WOULD MODERNIZE STATE LAWS
GOVERNING COMMUNICATION FOR
SAFETY NET PROGRAMS.
MORE THAN FOUR MILLION
CALIFORNIANS OVER HALF OF WHOM
ARE CHILDREN RELY ON CALPERS
BENEFITS FOR FOOD.
OVER ONE MILLION CALIFORNIANS
RECEIVE FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE
FROM CAL WORKS NUMBER THIRTEEN
MILLION CALIFORNIANS DEPEND ON
THAT ACCOUNT FOR HEALTH CARE THE
SAFETY NET PROGRAMS OUR FIRST
LINE OF DEFENSE AGAINST HUNGER
AND POVERTY IN CALIFORNIA.
HOWEVER STATE LAWS GOVERNING
COMMUNICATION FOR THESE CRITICAL
PROGRAMS HAVE NOT KEPT UP WITH
CHANGING TECHNOLOGY.
NEW METHODS SUCH AS COMPUTER
GENERATED TEXTING AND OTHER
ELECTRONIC TECHNOLOGIES OFFER
ACCESSIBLE EFFICIENT AND
COMMONPLACE OPTIONS FOR LOW
INCOME FAMILIES WHO MAY FACE
SIGNIFICANT COMMUNICATION
BARRIERS.
THESE NEW TECHNOLOGIES ALSO
PRESENT THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BETTER PROTECT CONFIDENTIAL
INFORMATION.
THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW ON LAW
AND POVERTY HAS FOUND THAT MANY
CLIENTS RECEIVING PUBLIC
BENEFITS.
FEEL LESS SECURE WITH THEIR
CONFIDENTIAL INFORMATION BEING
SENT.
TRADITIONAL MALE.
THIS IS BECAUSE MANY FAMILIES ON
PUBLIC BENEFITS MAY MOVE
FREQUENTLY OR LIVE IN SHARED
HOUSING. AND GIVEN THE HOUSING
CRISIS ELECTRONIC COMMUNICATION
CAN PRESENT A MORE PRIVATE AND
SECURE OPTION.
THE PERIOD NOT A COMA.
COUNTIES ARE DOING THEIR BEST TO
INCREASE ACCESS TO APPLICATIONS
FORMS AND NOTICES ELECTRONICALLY
BUT NEED CERTAINTY FROM THE
STATE.
AND WE'VE SEEN THAT NEW
TECHNOLOGY CAN GENERATE
INCREDIBLE RESULTS.
SENATE CLARA COUNTY HAS
IMPLEMENTED CONFERENCE OF TEXT
VOICE MAIL AND EMAIL
TECHNOLOGIES AND THEY'VE REDUCED
TURN TO UNDER ONE PERCENT
COMPARED TO TWELVE PERCENT
STATEWIDE AND THEY SIGNIFICANTLY
REDUCED WAIT TIMES.
BUT WITHOUT GUIDANCE FROM THE
STATE
COUNTIES MAY BEDISCOURAGED FROM
IMPLEMENTING NEW TECHNOLOGY.
THEREFORE AB NINETEEN FIFTY
SEVEN WOULD AUTHORIZE AND SET
PARAMETERS FOR ELECTRONIC
COMMUNICATION.
THIS BILL WOULD ESTABLISH THE
RIGHT OF APPLICANTS AND
RECIPIENTS TO RECEIVE ELECTRONIC
COMMUNICATION AND ENDED WHEN
THEY NO LONGER WANT TO RECEIVE
IT.
AB NINETEEN FIFTY SEVEN WOULD
ALSO REQUIRE THAT NOTICES BE
SENT VIA SECURED SERVER AND WOOD
ENSURE THE COMMUNICATION
COMPLIES WITH STATE SECURITY
STANDARDS.
AS WE LOOK TOWARDS MODERNIZATION
AND I WANT TO NOTE THAT
TECHNOLOGIES ONLY HELPFUL FOR
THOSE WHO HAVE ACCESS TO IT.
THIS BILL CONSIDERS THAT REALITY
BY PRESERVING THE RIGHT TO
RECEIVE INFORMATION VIA
TRADITIONAL MALE.
AB NINETEEN FIFTY SEVEN WILL
BRING OUR LAWS GOVERNING
COMMUNICATION FOR SAFETY NET
PROGRAMS INTO THE TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY AND ENSURE THAT WE
PROTECT THE PRIVACY AND DUE
PROCESS RIGHTS.
OF CALIFORNIANS WHOIS WHO RELY
ON THESE PROGRAMS FOR THEIR
BASIC NEEDS.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS
BILL. AND I'LL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS
STATED IN THE ANALYSIS TO ENSURE
THE PRIVACY OF APPLICANTS
RECIPIENTS AND COUNTY HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY EMPLOYEES AND IN
SHORT CLARITY.
THIS BILL IS SPONSORED BY THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF FOOD BANKS. AND
THE COALITION OF OF CALIFORNIA
WELFARE RIGHTS ORGANIZATIONS AND
HAS NO OPPOSITION AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU.
HELLO I'M SENDING MACALLAN THE
OF VICE PRESIDENT COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT POLICY BUT THE SECOND
HARVEST FOOD BANK OF SANTA
CLARENCE MATEO COUNTIES. HAD
BEEN AFFILIATED WITH THE FOOD
BANK IN OF WORK BUT SOCIAL
SERVICES AGENCY FOR OVER THIRTY
YEARS. I CURRENTLY CO CHAIR OF
THE SENATE CLARA COUNTY SAFETY
NET COMMITTEE WITH SOCIAL
SERVICES.
DURING MY TIME AT THE FOOD BANK
I'VE SEEN FIRST HAND THE
BARRIERS THAT PEOPLE FACE WHEN
SEEKING BENEFITS.
CONSUMERS MUST COMPLETE THE
NUMBER OF STEPS IN ORDER TO
SECURE AND MAINTAIN BENEFITS
SOME OF THE STEPS RELY ON
OUTDATED TECHNOLOGY AND BUSINESS
PRACTICES SUCH AS REQUIRING HARD
COPIES OF DOCUMENTS LIKE
PAYCHECK STUBS.
FOR MANY OF OUR FAMILIES THEY
HAVE LIMITED TIME THEIR JUGGLING
YOUR REGULAR WORK SHIFTS.
TRANSPORTATION CHALLENGES AND
HAVE THE RECALL HAVING THE
REQUIRED PAPERWORK CAN BE VERY
STRESSFUL.
HAVING TO PHYSICALLY GO TO A
SOCIAL SERVICES OFFICE FOR
ROUTINE APPOINTMENTS CAN BE A
CHALLENGE.
SUDDEN GAPS AND ACCESS TO FOOD
CREATES HUNGER HARDSHIP AND
INSTABILITY IN THE FAMILIES THAT
WE SERVE.
THE PROBLEM FAMILIES LOSING
BENEFITS WHILE STILL BEING
ELIGIBLE THEN QUICKLY REAPPLYING
IS CALLED TURN.
RE APPLICATIONS FOR BENEFITS
GENERATES REDUNDANT PAPERWORK
FOR FAMILY SEEKING ASSISTANCE
AND THE FIFTY EIGHT CALIFORNIA
COUNTY SOCIAL SERVICES AGENCIES
ASSISTED BY THEM.
WHEN FAMILIES LOSE BENEFITS MORE
PRESSURE IS PUT ON ORGANIZATIONS
SUCH AS OUR FOOD BANK.
AND OUR FOOD ASSISTANCE NETWORK
AND WE HAVE LIMITED RESOURCES
THAT ARE ALREADY BEING STRETCHED
TO CAPACITY.
HOW TECHNOLOGY CAN HELP US IN
MANY MANY WAYS SECOND HARVEST
FOOD BANKS WORKS WAS TO COUNTY
SANTA CLARA AND SAN MATEO
COUNTIES? THAT ADMINISTER PUBLIC
BENEFITS SUCH AS CAL FRESH.
IN SANTA CLARA COUNTY I HAVE
SEEN THE IMPACTS OF THIS FORWARD
THINKING.
THEY HAVE M. PLUMMETED A NUMBER
OF ROBUST ELECTRONIC
COMMUNICATIONS EFFORTS THAT
STREAMLINED PROCESSES. REDUCE
CHURN BOOSTED CLIENT SERVICES
TECHNOLOGY HAS BEEN USED FOR
TASKS SUCH AS SENDING OUT
REMINDER TEXTS FOR SUBMITTING
REPORTING FORMS. AND REQUIRED
VERIFICATIONS IN ORDER DIRECT
EVER RE CERTIFIED THEIR
ELIGIBILITY TO CONTINUE
RECEIVING BENEFITS.
REQUIRED VERIFICATIONS CAN BE
PROVIDED BY TAKING A PICTURE
USING A SMARTPHONE RATHER THAN
COMING INTO A SOCIAL SERVICES
OFFICE OFFICE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO YOU
TODAY WE APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL AND I'D BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
MIGHT HAVE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIRWOMAN
DISCOVER FLOW WITH THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY I KNOW
WE ARE HERE AS A SPONSOR AND
SUPPORT HIS ONE EMPHASIZE THAT
THIS BILL IS IS DOING TWO
THINGS.
UP FIRST IT'S CREATING THE SPACE
FOR COUNTIES TO KNOW THAT THEY
CAN MOVE FORWARD AND DEVELOP THE
MODERN TECHNOLOGY TO SERVE THE
CLIENTS AND THE COMMUNITY AND
THE INTEGRITY OF THE PROGRAM THE
BEST.
ON THE OTHER SIDE TO ALSO MAKE
SURE THAT THE CLIENTS RIGHTS AND
RESPONSIVE AT THE RIGHT THE
RESPONSIBILITIES ARE WELL
COMMUNICATED TO THEM AND THAT
THEY'RE DUE PROCESS IS
PROTECTED.
AS WE MOVE FORWARD IT IT'S A
SPACE WHERE THERE'S.
OR SO WORKING UP THE LANGUAGE
AND AND HOW TO TALK ABOUT IT AND
HOW IT HAD CODIFY IT AND SO I
JUST A QUICK THANK YOU TO YOU
AND YOUR STAFF. OF FOR WORKING
WITH US ON THE LANGUAGE AS WE
MOVE FORWARD AND AND YOU KNOW
AND UP TO THIS POINT IT'S BEEN
REALLY HELPFUL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU TURNER THROUGH CHORUS A
CALIFORNIA OFFER RIGHTS
ORGANIZATIONS CLOSE MONTHS IN
THE BILL AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU UP ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
OTHER CHAIR MEMBERS KERR CHILD
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
WHERE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
WE ALWAYS APPRECIATE WHEN
TECHNOLOGY IS AVAILABLE TO MAKE
CAP BENEFITS MORE ACCESSIBLE.
TO INDIVIDUALS WITH.
DISABILITIES AND WE ALSO
APPRECIATE WORKING WITH THE
AUTHORS OFFICE TO ENSURE THAT
INDEED THE TECHNOLOGY THAT USED
IN THIS CASE IS ACCESSIBLE
TECHNOLOGY THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
HI THERE SARAH PALMER TO FRANK
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF FOOD
BANKS ALSO A CO SPONSOR. AND
WE'RE JUST VERY EXCITED ABOUT
THIS BILL NOT ONLY INCREASING
ACCESS.
TO THE BENEFIT.
ALSO HELPING COUNTIES JUST.
WAY THE FOUNDATION TO PERHAPS
REDUCE CHURN INCREASE OF
INCREASED EFFICIENCY THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
KELLY WORKS ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION WE HAVE A SUPPORT IN
CONCEPT POSITION WE THINK IT'S A
GOOD IDEA TO DEVELOP SOME
STATEWIDE STANDARDS FOR COUNTIES
TO FOLLOW WHEN DEVELOPING APPS
AND OTHER NEW TECHNOLOGIES TO
COMMUNICATE WITH CLIENTS. UNTIL
NOW COUNTIES HAVE LARGELY DONE
THIS ON THEIR OWN OR IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH TECH COMPANIES
ARE NON PROFITS. WE THINK WE'VE
DONE A GOOD JOB OF PROTECTING
PRIVACY IN PRESERVING TRACE BUT
THEY'RE LIKELY SOME DIFFERENCES
A COST COUNTIES AND THE
DIFFERENT.
APPS SYSTEM THAT THEY'D ABOUT
DEVELOPED AND IT SENSIBLE TO PUT
SOME STATEWIDE STANDARDS IN
PLACE WE WORKED WITH THE AUTHOR
SPONSOR AND COMMITTEE STOP ON
SOME INITIAL AMENDMENTS THERE IS
STILL WORK TO BE DONE.
BUT WE'RE ALL COMMITTED TO
GETTING THERE AND WE'RE
COMFORTABLE WITH MOVING THE BILL
FOR TODAY.
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
GET OUT GOING TO BRING IT UP TO
THE COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS.
GET IBM MOTION BY DUCT CHOICE
SECOND BY A DOCTOR ARAMBULA.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE TO SIT
VERY QUICKLY AS YOU KNOW MANY OF
US FOR THE LOCAL FOOD BANK OVER
LUNCH VOLUNTEERING.
AND WE WERE TAX TALKING ABOUT
REDUCING BARRIERS TO TO FOOD
BANKS AND OTHER SERVICES THAT
FOLKS IN THE COMMUNITY AND
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO DO HERE.
SO I REALLY APPRECIATE ALL YOUR
WORK YOUR HELP WITH THE WITH THE
BILL AND.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU CAN YOU CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE.
RUBIO I REVEAL AYE DOCTOR CHOI.
DUCKS CHOI AYE ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I MAIENSCHEIN.
THERE'S.
THERE'S AYE STONE.
STONE AYE THURMOND.
BILLS PIPES HERE GAVE THE UP THE
RECOMMENDATION WAS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE PRIVACY AND
CONSUMER PROTECTION COMMITTEE
AND IT MOVES OUT FIVE ZERO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
DOCTOR ARAMBULA.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
LET ME START BY ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS NOTED IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS AND THANKS TO
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH MY OFFICE TO CLARIFY THE
LANGUAGE OF THIS BILL.
AB TWENTY TWO NINETY SEVEN WAS
INTRODUCED TO HELP PREVENT
HUNGER IN OUR STATE.
FOUR MILLION CALIFORNIANS
STRUGGLE WITH FOOD INSECURITIES
EVERYDAY.
THE SUPPLEMENTAL NUTRITION
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM KNOWN AS CAL
FRESH IN CALIFORNIA IS OUR MOST
IMPORTANT DEFENSE AGAINST
HUNGER.
WELL MANY RELY ON THIS BENEFIT
IT AMOUNTS TO LESS THAN TWO
DOLLARS PER MEAL.
ACCORDING TO THE NATIONAL
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION THIS AMOUNT
IS LESS THAN WHAT IS NEEDED TO
PURCHASE A HEALTHY DIET.
BECAUSE BENEFITS ARE SO LOW
NEARLY ONE THIRD OF HOUSEHOLDS
THAT RECEIVE SNAP BENEFITS
STILL MUST RELY ON FOOD BANKS TO
MEET THEIR BASIC NEEDS FOR FOOD.
THE AMERICAN RECOVERY AND
REINVESTMENT ACT OF TWO THOUSAND
AND NINE INCREASED MONTHLY. CAL
FRESH BENEFITS.
BOOSTING THEIR PURCHASING POWER
SO THAT THEY MAY AVERT HUNGER
AND ALSO HELPED STIMULATE THE
ECONOMY.
THIS INCREASE IN MONTHLY FOOD
BENEFIT LASTED ONLY UNTIL
OCTOBER OF TWENTY THIRTEEN.
HOWEVER THE INCREASE IN BENEFIT
WAS DOCUMENTED TO HAVE REDUCED
INCIDENCE OF HUNGER AND
INCREASING A PURCHASING OF
HEALTHY FOOD.
SINCE THE ARE A BOOST OF SNAP
BENEFITS WAS TERMINATED THE
AVERAGE FAMILY OF THREE HAS HAD
THEIR BENEFITS REDUCED BY TWENTY
EIGHT DOLLARS PER MONTH.
AB TWENTY TWO NINETY SEVEN
PROVIDES A TWENTY EIGHT DOLLAR
INCREASED TO CAL FRESH MONTHLY
BENEFITS.
THE POOREST FAMILIES WITH
CHILDREN OFTEN FACE THE MOST
SEVERE FOOD SHORTAGES.
SPECIALLY WHEN THEY LACK ACCESS
TO CLEAN WATER OR MEMBERS OF THE
FAMILY HAVE MEDICAL CONDITIONS
THAT RESULT IN HIGHER FOOD
COSTS.
INCREASING THE MONTHLY BENEFIT
IN THE PROGRAM WILL HELP PREVENT
HUNGER.
SUPPORT HEALTHY FOOD PURCHASES
STIMULATE THE ECONOMY AND CREATE
JOBS.
ADDITIONALLY STATE LAW ALLOWS
FOR SPECIAL NEEDS ALLOWANCE FOR
RECIPIENTS ON CAL WORKS WHEN THE
RECIPIENT HAS A DIET RELATED
DISEASE THAT REQUIRES A SPECIAL
DIET.
AB TWENTY TWO NINETY SEVEN MAKES
A CHANGE TO THE CAL WORKS
SPECIAL FOOD BENEFIT.
SO THAT IT IS DELIVERED ON AB T.
AS A FOOD BENEFIT RATHER THAN A
CAST BENEFIT WHERE IT WOULD BE
COUNT. COUNTABLE INCOME IN CAL
FRESH.
IT ALSO ADDS LACK OF FRESH WATER
AND HIGH LEAD BLOOD LEVELS AS
REASONS TO RECEIVE THE COW WORK
SPECIAL FOODS. NEEDS SUPPLEMENT.
AND IT CODIFIES THE CURRENT
GUIDANCE OF THE AMOUNT OF
SPECIAL NEEDS SUPPLEMENT AT
FIFTEEN DOLLARS.
WITH ME TODAY IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL ARE ANDREW SHANE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF FOOD
BANKS AND STEVE SUMMERS A CAL
FRESH RECIPIENT.
THANK YOU.
AT MY NAME IS STEPHEN SOMMERS I
LIVE IN OAKLAND I'M SIX
A TWO YEARS OLD AND I.
THE MACAU FRESH RECIPIENT ON AND
OFF CENTS.
THE GREAT RECESSION IN TWO
THOUSAND AND NINE.
.
OVER THAT TIME A BEING ON CAL
FRESH AND WHEN I WAS HOMELESS.
CAL FRESH HELPED ME TO.
MAKE GOOD CHOICES FOR HEALTHY
MEALS.
WHEN I WAS UNEMPLOYED AFTER AND
AFTER BECOMING HOMELESS AFTER
WORKING MY WAY OUT IN GETTING A
JOB IT WENT OFF.
CAL FRESH  I LOST THAT JOB.
THAT THEM MYSELF BACK ON CAL
FRESH DURING THAT TIME. USING
CAL FRESH HELP WE HAVE TO.
BUT IT MADE ME OF VOID USING
THEY'RE HAVING TO MAKE THE
CHOICE BETWEEN.
RENT AND FOOD.
SO IT LITERALLY HELP ME I STAY
IN MY SHELTER.
NOW DAYS I'M STILL ON CAL FRESH
I WORK TWENTY HOURS A WEEK FOR
THE CITY OF OAKLAND.
I GET A HUNDRED AND TWENTY ONE
DOLLARS A MONTH.
.
AND.
I JUST WANT TO SAY.
I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
AND RESTORING THE TWENTY EIGHT
DOLLAR.
CUT.
I CAN TELL YOU FROM FIRST HAND
EXPERIENCE THAT.
EVEN WITH THE CAL FRESH BENEFITS
I GET IT'S NOT ENOUGH TO COVER
MY MONTHLY FOOD BUDGET.
IT'S A CONSTANT PUZZLE TO PUT
TOGETHER.
HOW I'M GOING TO COVER IT?
I.
USE MY CAL FRESH BENEFITS.
I ALSO GO TO A FOOD DISTRIBUTION
ONCE A WEEK.
TO MAKE UP FOR THE SLACK. AND I
SPEND MY OWN. MY OWN MONEY FROM
MY JOB TO COVER MY.
FOOD UP COST.
SO IT'S A CONSTANT PUZZLE TO
PUT THAT TOGETHER EVERY MONTH.
AND.
.
YOU KNOW FOR ME.
I'M BETTER OFF THAN MOST CAL
FRESH RECIPIENTS BECAUSE I LIVE
NEAR. A FULL SERVICE GROCERY
STORE I HAD THE ABILITY TO COOK
MEALS I HAD THE ABILITY TO TAKE.
ADVANTAGE OF SALES I KID MEAL
PLAN AND MANY PEOPLE ON CAL
FRESH OR UNABLE TO DO THESE
THINGS SO.
THAT GAP IS GETTING HARDER TO
CLOSE AND EVEN FOR ME WHO'S
SOME.
YOU KNOW RELATIVELY.
I WANT TO SAY WELL OFF ON CAL
FRESHMAN HAVE MANY OF THE
ADVANTAGES THAT A LOT OF.
CALVET BIAN'S DON'T GET SO I
URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
AND.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BRINGING
IT FORWARD. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS A
INTERCHANGE IN THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF FOOD BANKS.
I CAN'T PUT IT BETTER THAN THAT
I WOULD JUST UNDERSCORE DOCTOR
ROMULUS POINT THAT THIS IS
UNFORTUNATELY.
STEVE STORIES IS FAR FROM THE
EXCEPTION.
YOU KNOW IT'S IN FACT NEARLY A
THIRD OF THE FOLKS WHO ARE ON
CONFERENCE RONSTADT ARE STILL
COMING TO FOOD BANKS BECAUSE OF
BENEFIT ADEQUACY. AND THAT
INADEQUACY IS A CHOICE HAS BEEN
MADE BY CONGRESS AND WE'RE HERE
TODAY ASKING THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO CONSIDER REVERSING
WHAT WAS KNOWN AS THE HUNGER
CLIFF IN TWENTY THIRTEEN. AND
RESTORE THOSE BENEFITS THAT WERE
SCIENTIFICALLY PROVEN TO FIGHT
HUNGER.
TO SUSTAIN THE ECONOMY AND TO
SUPPORT HEALTHY EATING I THINK
GOALS THAT WE CAN ALL SUPPORT
AND CYPRESS YOUR CONSIDERATION
OF THAT AND I WOULD JUST MAKE
TWO. TWO POINTS.
WHICH IS THAT THIS IF WE DON'T
DO THIS THIS COMES WITH CERTAIN
COSTS TO OUR STATE.
AND THAT'S BECAUSE WHAT HAPPENS
IS THAT FOLKS ARE COMING TO FOOD
BANKS OR THEY'RE THEY'RE NOT
RUNNING OUT OF FOOD JUST ONE
TIME THAT THIS IS HAPPENING
EVERY MONTH. AND THAT MEANS THAT
FUNDAMENTALLY THERE'S UNMET NEED
BECAUSE OF STEVE POINTED OUT NO
ONE CAN NOT NEVER CAN GET TO A
FOOD BANK I THINK IS OFTEN THAT
MYTH THAT COULD MAKE HER JUST
JUST THERE WITH FOOD EVERY DAY
pSEVEN NO WE. THE SERVICES ARE
ARE LIMITED IN THERE'S DISTANCES
AND AND AND REAL COSTS AND TIME
INVESTMENTS THERE. AND MEANWHILE
HOSPITALIZATION SPIKE IN THE
FOURTH WEEK OF THE MONTH WHEN
FOOD BUDGETS RUN OUT BOOKS CAN
TAKE THEIR MEDS AND THE REST OF
THE STORY THAT WE KNOW. AND I
AND ADDITIONALLY THE FOOD BANKS
IN THEY'RE BUILT FOR THIS WE'RE
BUILT FOR OCCASIONAL TEMPORARY
SUPPORT AND THAT'S SIMPLY AND
INCREASINGLY LESS THAN WAS THE
CASE AS HOUSING PRESSURES AND
OTHERS THAT HE SPOKE TO. YOU
KNOW CONTINUE MEANWHILE
CONFERENCE IN THAT MEETING THE
NEED IT THAT IS MEANT TO DO SO.
FEDERATION
THANK YOU.
SACRAMENTO ON MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE JESSICA BARTH OVER THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY AND WE'RE SPONSOR AND
SUPPORT AND THANK YOU MISTER
SUMMERS FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
GOVERNOR THROUGH COALITION
CALIFORNIA WOLFOWITZ
ORGANIZATIONS WE'VE BEEN DOING
THIS FOR PERCENT TRANSIT.
ALWAYS
FOLKS WERE OUT OF FOOD THE
FOURTH WEEK OF THE MONTH THEY
START. THAT'S HORRIBLE AND WHERE
DID I PUT.
THANK YOU I ANY OTHER.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
CINDY MCCOWN WHAT THE SECOND
HARVEST FOOD BANK OF SANTA
CLARINETIST.
SHE'S IN SUPPORT.
THERAPY HOMER TO FRANK WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HUNGER ACTION
COALITION I WANNA ECHO MISTER
SUMMERS TESTIMONY.
AS A FORMER CATFISH RECIPIENT
AND SINGLE MOTHER IT WAS VERY
DIFFICULT FOR ME TO PROVIDE FOOD
FOR MY DAUGHTER AND MYSELF WELL
I WAS GOING TO SCHOOL.
I WOULD SUGGEST
REALLY FROM MY HEART.
HEARD YOU ALSO SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
SELENA PRIOR SEIU CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
KELLY BROUGHT SOME BEHALF OF THE
SENATE CLARA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS HEARINGS.
THANK.
HER CHILD DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
OKAY WITH THAT I'LL BRING IT UP
TO THE COMMITTEE.
THIS RACE.
I DO WANNA THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD
SOMETIMES WE DON'T REALIZE THAT
WE CAN HELP.
TO SOLVE THE ISSUES BECAUSE BY
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
AND I THINK THIS IS AN EASY FIX.
COURSE WITH FINE THE MONEY IN
THE BUDGET. BUT IT IS AN EASY
FIX I DO APPRECIATE SIR YOUR
YOUR TESTIMONY IT ALWAYS MAKES A
DIFFERENCE WHEN WE HAVE.
A FACE TO THE PROBLEM OF BECAUSE
YOU ARE ALSO THE FACE TO THE
SOLUTION THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
CANADA MOTION I. THINK.
KEVIN MOTION AND THE MOST.
WOULD BE TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE AND
AGAIN JUST FOR CLARIFICATION YOU
ACCEPT THEM AND THAT'S.
THANK YOU.
BUT THAT WOULD TO LIKE TO CLOSE
WITH RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY
VOTE.
THANK YOU CAN YOU CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE.
RUBIO ARE RUBIO AYE DOCTOR CHOI.
DOCTOR CHOI NO ARAMBULA AYE AYE
ARAMBULA AYE MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I DRESS.
THERE'S I'VE STONE. STONE AYE
THURMOND. THURMOND AYE BILL
SKETCH SIX
ONE CAME THE BILL MOVES OUT SIX
ONE TWO.
AS AMENDED TO PREPARATIONS
THANK YOU.
OKAY AND THEN I'LL WITH DAD WE
HEARD ALL THE BILLS ARE A WILL
LIFT THE CALL FOR.
.
THE.
YES
.
OKAY WILCO HAD IN A WITH THE.
SIXTEEN NINETY FOUR.
YES WILL GO AT IT BUT IF THE
CALL ON ASSEMBLY MEMBER FLORIST
BILL.
AB NINETEEN FOURTEEN
OKAY.
FOR THE CONSECUTIVE.
ITEM NUMBER ONE AB EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY THREE ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB
TWENTY THIRTY ITEM NUMBER SEVEN
AB TWENTY TWO SIXTY NINE. ITEM
NUMBER NINE AB TWENTY THREE
THIRTEEN ITEM NUMBER TEN AB
TWENTY THREE THIRTY SEVEN ITEM
NUMBER TWELVE AB TWENTY THREE
NINETY SEVEN AND ACR WENT
SEVENTEEN ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN.
MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN AYE. THURMAN.
THURMOND I.
YOURSELF.
SO I QUIT LEFT THE CALL ON A
BEING NINETEEN FIFTY SEVEN ITEM
NUMBER THREE.
TO PASS A MANDATE TO THE PRIVACY
AND CONSUMER PROTECTION
COMMITTEE.
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
THURMOND. THURMOND AYE.
THE BILL'S AT SEVEN CHAIR QUE
BELT SEVEN ZERO.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB TWENTY TO
FORTY FOUR ASSEMBLY MEMBER CUP
ACOSTA.
DO PASSED TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
I RAMBLE LA.
HOLD ON GOT MY PENCIL.
ARAMBULA I MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN AYE THURMOND.
THURMOND AYE BILLS GET SEVEN
ZERO OKAY.
AND MOVES OUT SEVEN ZERO.
ITEM NUMBER SIX.
ITEM SIX TWO.
AB TWO TWO FOUR SEVEN.
AB TWENTY TO FORTY SEVEN
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GIPSON.
DO PASSED AMENITY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN AYE THURMAN.
THURMOND I.
BILLS GET SENT EACH YEAR.
ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN AB TWENTY
THREE SEVENTY ASSEMBLYMEMBERS
HOLDEN.
DO PASSAGE AMENDED TO THE
ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY AND TALK.
SAFETY AND TOXIC MATERIALS
COMMITTEE.
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
STONE UP I'M SORRY THURMAN.
THURMOND DAY.
ALL I'M SORRY RAYOS.
READ HIS.
RARE SITE THE BILL'S GOT SEVEN
TO ZERO.
IT WOULD GET RID OF IT.
ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN.
ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN AB SIXTEEN
NINETY FOUR ASSEMBLY MEMBER MARK
STONE BILL SWELLED TO CONCURRENT
SENATE AMENDMENTS.
AND RE REFER TO THE FLOOR.
MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I.
THURMOND.
THURMOND I.
BILLS GET SEVEN TO ZERO.
RIGHT CLICK WITH THAT WILL GO
AHEAD AND ADJOURN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE'LL SEE YOU IN A COUPLE
WEEKS